[Musique]
pire ils 614 bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinker view nous sommes en
direct est ce que vous connaissez la
chaîne internet oui je les ai vus j'ai
regardé plusieurs vidéos vidéos
passionnante bien souvent toujours même
donc la connaît bien sûr qu'elle vide
vous avez trouvé passionnante je
regardais un petit peu celle qui ce qui
se rapportait à mon sujet donc j'ai vu
celle de monsieur alain juillet qui
était particulièrement réussie je pense
qu'il parle il parle très bien il est
très à l'aise s'était détendue s'était
essayée très bien plus récemment ma
comme j'ai su que je venais dans vos
studios j'ai regardé les vidéos plus
récentes on guérit connaissez très bien
aussi et puis j'avais vu un scientifique
sur des sujets beaucoup plus intime
qu'un
c'était passionnant il parlait très bien
d'un sujet très compliqué et avec des
mots très simples très pédago voilà
c'était c'était très bien on poursuit
aujourd'hui pour finir un cycle
deux vidéos qu'on a fait autour du
renseignement comme vous avez pu le
remarquer d'ailleurs
on va parler expérience de terrain on va
parler de vos 15 ans dans les services
s'est peut-être de vo 13 ans en tant que
militaire avant
donc vous avez un pseudo cb 1614 ou 6 14
vous avez 49 ans et quatre enfants deux
femmes du moins à divorcer
vous vous avez selon votre légende votre
famille musicienne du moins professeur
de musique à votre dernière parce que
j'ai mis ça dans le papier de libération
bon allez et donc on n'a pas cherché à
avoir sur
votre femme est on est on en train de
chercher votre identité
ça a l'air d'être facile de le trouver
non il ya des abonnés qui me kiffe
fouilles qui aime qui aime chercher et
j'ai fait quelques erreurs donc il ya
certains qui on arrive ils sont arrivés
à ma véritable identité ils ont eu la
politesse la gentillesse de pains de pas
l'évoquer je tiens à rester voilà resté
caché savais qu'ici on est très poli
voilà je suis pas très inquiet mais je
vais donc si vous amusez vous à trouver
à chercher vos arriverait je pense mais
si vous trouvez je vous donnerai la
réponse est oui ou non mais on ne dit
pas c'est à notre communauté parce
qu'ils sont vraiment très
bons qu'on va commencer comme vous le
savez comme je vous ai annoncé je ne
prépare pas les questions pour nous
j'aimerais qu'on aborde
la conscience de l'homme de rance de
renseignement
vous avez dit dans un papier que du
moment que c'est pour une démocratie que
tout se passe bien que ces carrés
c'est ok
vous vous maintenez ça je le maintiens
je persiste et je signe mais c'est une
question c'est évidemment une très bonne
question surtout quand on travaille sur
du renseignement quand on manipule des
sources qu'on peut on trahit ont trahi
la confiance peut-être dans certains cas
donc évidemment sur les questions très
sensibles et on pense toujours à ce côté
moral
et j'ai toujours été très clair avec ça
personnellement je vous dis si jamais on
me demande d ordre et je suis j'ai trouv
par rapport à ma morale ma propre morale
mon propre système de valeur nets
intelligente oui j'espère on sait qu'il
faut c'est qu'on est théorique des
baïonnettes intelligente moi je vais pas
vous allez me le dire mais je en tout
cas pour répondre à la question de
savoir la conscience
on sait j'étais toujours prêt
intellectuellement je m'étais préparé à
refuser a donc à démissionner s'il
fallait parce qu'évidemment un militaire
qui le dg ceux qui refusent d'obéir aux
ordres comme un peu gênant donc à ce
moment-là faut assumer on veut dire donc
non je refuse de répondre à cet ordre
parce qu'il est illégal parce que c'est
pas normal parce que c'est je m'arme
amoral ne l'acceptent pas et donc à ce
moment là je prends les conséquences de
cette décision et je démissionne c'est
un jeu j'étais toujours prêt à ça mais
je n'ai jamais eu à le faire parce qu'un
ordre donné doit être exécuté sans et
discuter oui alors dans notre formation
d'officiers et ça avant la dgse on nous
a collé vous nous inculque quand même à
apprendre toujours du recul et à pas
réitérer les ordres du nazisme donc des
sommes manifestement illégaux donc on
nous apprend le droit international et
même à des officiers
on leur dit attention obéissez au bseo
glissé on nous apprend aussi à à dire
non un ordre manifestement illégal si on
nous demande de torture et oui non je
refuse de torture si on vous demande
d'aller assassiner des gens en afrique
bon ben laden mort des scénarios rey a
aucune raison qu'on me le demande me
poser la boutade
pas forcément
ce qu'un président ne doit pas dire
ouais ouais ouais
donc assassiné des gens en affection
demande d'assassiner non j'aurais eu
beaucoup de mal ce n'était pas moi
j'étais officier de renseignement donc
je vais armen du renseignement le
renseignement il tue pas peux-tu et
d'ailleurs mais on décompte plus
maintenant
mais donc j'ai jamais été confronté à ce
genre de à ce genre de choses
d'extrémité j'ai jamais eu besoin de
refuser un ordre et donc ma conscience a
toujours été pendant ses 15 ans c'est
quand même pas rien j'ai jamais eue on
m'a jamais demandé de faire des choses
lamentables décalé voilà c'est aussi
peut-être parce que je travaille pour un
service de renseignements français
peut-être que si j'étais espions de la
cia ce n'aurait pas été la même chose je
pense que la cia se permet plus de
choses on viendra sur la cia et tous ses
petits copains contractuels
revenons en revenons à la france
quand un président dit que nous avons
des assassins
qui se passe de tribunaux
ça vous fait quoi en tant que ex agent
de la dgse le que cette façon d'aller
rendre justice
en foulant aux pieds nos lois
donc on peut reprendre le titre de
l'étude de l'insee un président ne
devrais pas dire ça donc c'est peut-être
c'était un bon titre
et c'est pas c'est pas moi ex agent de
la dgse de de commenter ou de fait des
révélations sur ce domaine là de dire
oui ça existe ou non ça n'existe pas
en tout cas d'opération moumoute me
connais tout le monde est connecté monde
en parle tout le monde y en a eu il y
avait eu des histoires du sdec l époque
c'étaient des choses qui se faisaient
qui se faisait peut-être assez
régulièrement mais il ya un côté
mythique où on se fait on se fait des
films très rapidement quand on parle de
renseignements c'est du secret donc on
imagine plein de choses et on imagine
que que les agents secrets les officiers
traitants de la dgse sont les assassins
en puissance donc ça c'est complètement
absurde c'est faux donc
voilà
on va revenir creuser sujet là un peu
après vous connaissez le principe c'est
0 2 a vous avez le temps de revenir et
ça part dans tous les sens et puis et
puis surtout j'ai à faire un
professionnel aujourd'hui
et l'interrogatoire va se passer
différemment
son interrogatoire il ya un gentil et un
méchant non mais là vous jouez de rôle
oui exactement mais pour vous faire que
mes changements d'accords dont quelle
est la différence du - quel est le point
commun entre vous et si je retrouve ma
ligne bougeait pas
des gens qui se trouvent à boulay les
trous des gens qui se trouvent
dans des ford ont des qg
de la dgse des qg de la dgsi quel est le
point commun maintenant tout de suite
mais c'est à dire je comprends pas
forcément des gens qui souffrent qui
travaille en ce moment la dgse
exactement si le point commun
ben je on a et on a fait le même métier
montrez nous votre montre d'accord voila
voila c'est une mode connecté apple et
donc j'ai beaucoup d'abonnés qui disent
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cet esprit
en toc ce fake en carton en carton qui a
une montre connecteurs pourquoi pourquoi
ils vous ont dit st
parce que c'est ils ont le droit de
penser ce qu'ils veulent briller voilà
il faut aiguiser son sens critique et on
y tient un espion il doit être discret
il doit pas se faire se faire avoir par
sa maman de connecter il géographique et
par la cia qui rentrait dans maman de
gmail man j'ai utilisé 26 utilise
haut-parleurs pour m'enregistrer
d'accord j'ai un copain qui journaliste
s'est pas de jean marc manach et qui
s'est amusé à goli vos petits camarades
ray applications de course avec les
piquets sont course parce que vous savez
comme ils sont très bien formés ces gens
là
qui scella les journalistes au le
finaliste coureurs les deux sont très
bien formés je pense peut-être un
puisque l'autre ils sont amusés à g que
géolocalisé en opex
sur certaines bases et mon pote les ago
les il y avait le numéro deux de la dgse
dans le dans le truc est ce qu'on
pensait pas que ça fait un peu amateur
payés avec nos impôts
ballon on évolue avec des réseaux
sociaux qui
on n'a pas encore conscience que c'est
notre vie qui se déroule jour après jour
et des fois on n'a pas encore conscience
donc il faut d'abord faire l'erreur pour
pouvoir ne plus les reproduire donc là
c'est ce qui s'est passé je pense qu'on
ne retrouvera plus des footings des gens
qui font leur footing en irak sur des
zones sensibles avec ses applications
donc je pense que les gens ont été
sanctionnés et puis et puis ensuite la
leçon est apprise ça ne se reproduira
plus ça arrive oui ça fait pas très
sérieux tous les services ont fait des
grosses erreurs des trucs un peu
ridicule les russes le fsb sont vus avec
des il faut pas juger mon père m'a
toujours appris que j'aime comparer ou
dernier la casse donc le
ccc alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et
qu'une monde connecté est-ce que vous
avez regardé un petit peu le soft
qu'est-ce que ça extraits comme données
qu'est ce que c'est bon je sais pas je
sais pas moi même très technique
en ce qui concerne les mesures de
sécurité pouvoir est-ce que je suis
détenteur de secrets qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire avec ma montre on peut
déclencher à distance mon haut-parleurs
et encore il faut faut être un service
comme déjà d'un très bon niveau
technique pour pouvoir rentrer dans le
logiciel de la montre et pui déclenché
mon haut parleurs bon là en tout cas
sûrement registre ça aucun intérêt je
suis en train de vous parler est
d'origine à rien seul faisait tout cuit
de la dgse vous amuser à faire un petit
coup un petit un petit footing puis
comme vous avez un petit peu fatigué
vous oublié de vous aider
géo localisées pardon et puis votre
copain à côté discute un peu et puis
votre copain à côté il ya un téléphone
ouais et puis grâce à votre monde qui
connecté à votre téléphone qui restaient
dans le petit coffre vous savez le petit
coffre un ou des son téléphone
et bah quand même on peut savoir quels
sont les numéros qui sont là mais moi je
suis berry a donné en étoile et puis et
puis le mec qui rentre chez lui le
week-end pays va continuer de courir
parce que c'est un petit peu son truc et
puis on peut on peut localiser parce que
on sait où il habite on peut faire
pression sur lui parce que on connaît
ses enfants et sa femme et puis imaginez
vous c'est le conte c'est le conducteur
d'un sous marin nucléaire
c'est comme ça qu'un sage et de
renseignement travaille c'est comme ça
qu'a renseignements alain service dans
ses entrailles comment ça se fait que
mes impôts ont servi à plier des
incapables
alors donc là en l'occurrence en parler
de mamans font trop départ donc là
maintenant faut voir de qui je me cache
est ce que j'ai des secrets déjà je ne
sais plus membre de la dgse donc donc si
un service de renseignement veut perdre
son temps et ses de trafic et ma montre
qu'à cela ne tienne il je pense qu'il
est mieux de mieux en mieux de chaume
des choses à meilleure affaire plus
intéressante une importante voie là et
donc de qui je me cache ensuite déjà je
sais plus détenteur de secrets et
ensuite
depuis je me cache faut voir voilà je me
cache pas de la cia je m'en fous si la
cia commence à essaimer que ça met plus
associe maintenance à ces mondes
connectés en service c'est dommage c'est
pas la peine
on est d'accord quels sont les risques
ça peut exploser réellement services par
exemple si mais qui fait c'est son petit
footing à vous l'avez vous même expliqué
si on commence à essayer de faire un
dossier de renseignements pour se dire
tiens à celui là il nous intéresse il
est a priori bien placé à dgse on veut
faire un dossier devrait essayer de le
recruter donc on veut savoir où est ce
qu'ils habitent est-ce que ça va bien
avec son couple ou est-ce que voilà on
rentre sur internet si normalement quand
on est officier traitant l'a déjà ce on
essaye d'éviter les réseaux sociaux mais
mais quelqu'un qui a les réseaux sociaux
sans on rentre dans sa vie et on essaie
de les voir des failles et puis on peut
monter une opération lourde cd toujours
des opérations l'ont pressé de recruter
un agent d'un service adverse ça ça
prend du temps donc donc là on facilite
le travail d'un train d'un service
adverse c'est vrai
c'est grave oui c'est grave alors
ensuite donc donc on évite de de
faciliter le travail des services
adverses on a un service de sécurité qui
est chargée aussi de nous contrôler
devoir nous en interne et donc il est
chargé disgrâce et les couilles ou si on
sera en l'occurrence pour pour
l'application de footing là ils peuvent
pas non plus de tout contrôler ils ont
ils ont ils doivent contrôler 5000
personnes dont ils agissent
on apprend en marchant et donc c'est pas
infaillible comme le terrorisme le
contre-terrorisme parfois il ya des
bombes qui explosent c'est pas
infaillible donc parfois on fait des
arts de sécurité mais ça ça arrive et il
faut il faut progresser il faut régler
les problèmes tels qu'ils arrivent un
par an et puis il est réglé s'améliorer
parce que le risque zéro n'existe pas
personne n'est parfait
est ce que pour vous bernard bajolet est
parfait
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça déjà oui
il a bien fait son travail
ce qui est pourquoi lui puisqu'un autre
en tout cas oui je pense que chaque j'ai
j'ai eu j'ai travaillé sous trois
directeurs généraux différents chacun a
apporté sa pierre à l'édifice et
monsieur pierre bageot les bas à
professionnaliser le service il avait un
très bon contact avec avec le présent le
hall anton qui plaçait la dgse un très
bon niveau de confiance avec le pouvoir
politique ce qui est toujours une bonne
chose donc la voilà déjà se comptaient
au travers de la voix de monsieur
bajolet ça s'éteint c'est une bonne
chose pour un service de renseignement
quand vous voyez
cet amateurisme de la montre connectés
ou quand vous voyez cet amateurisme sur
le l'anticipation crise à l'extérieur de
du territoire français je vous parle des
révolutions arabes sur la dgs ou n'a
jamais eu vinet beaucoup évolué mais
parce que oui bah oui on peut on peut
faire des procès de la dgse des services
c'est pas un procès c'est une
constatation c'est une cata sensation
oui vraiment pas vrai baverel c'est un
procès où c'est une constatation c'est
une peut faire ce constat il ya d'autres
choses on peut parler aussi des états
islamiques que pas que pourtant on
faisait de contreterrorisme depuis
longtemps on a des textes islamiques
encore ça où on en viendra peut-être
mais c'est déjà aussi des erreurs de
service mais voilà c'est c'est la
matière du renseignement lé elle est
complexe n'est pas facile si c'était
facile ça serait
pas la peine d'avoir un service de
renseignement donc le renseignement
c'est une matière c'est de l'humain
souvent donc même si c'est du
renseignement technique en partie il
faut l'analyser et donc on peut se
tromper toujours donc il faut faut que
savoir toujours avoir cet esprit
critique c'est ce que vous demandez à
votre communauté aussi de ne pas prendre
ce que disent les gens pour argent
comptant il faut toujours garder son
esprit critique parce que même un
service qui se veut professionnel qui a
beaucoup de moyens financiers pays les
impôts
peut se tromper alors il essaie de se
tromper le moins possible et parfois ils
voient pas les choses en avance alors
qu'il aurait dû mérite donné c'est que
vous avez vu il n'ya pas longtemps
expliqué ça c'est bien en temps c'est la
révolution arabe un service fait mal ça
prospectives ils n'arrivent pas à
prévoir ce qui va se passer dans trois à
cinq ans mais quand il ya quelque chose
qui arrive on lui tient fouillé mois sa
fille et moi cet individu c'est quoi son
environnement familial c'est quoi ces
failles c'est quoi ce contrat
donc là quand on lui demande quoi
chercher il va mettre les moyens il va
trouver
et ensuite il ya eu des erreurs c'est
dommage bien sûr d'accord
mais tout n'est pas à jeter je vais être
moins gentil avec vous qui avec eric
dénécé d'accord parce que vous avez une
expérience de terrain et l'expérience de
terrain et toujours
c'est de l'or est critiquable non c'est
de l'or c'est plus respectable
contrairement tous ceux qui déambulent
dans les salons feutrés ou dans les
paquets donc soirée spectacle donc on
attaque fort bien sûr pas d'accord qui
est bien châtie bien plus d'accord pas
d'accord samba rue d'accord pour est
d'accord quand vous voyez ça
vous vous êtes censé ramener du
renseignement brut vous êtes censé
ramener une prospective avec une petite
interprétation ou c'est que du brut
mais ça dépend donc il ya il ya des
agents de terrain quand on est en poste
à l'extérieur on envoie du brut
essentiellement donc c'est c'est du brut
qui remonte à paris à la centrale et à
la centrale on a les analystes qui eux
récupèrent tout le brut de tous les
postes qui récupère les interceptions
qui récupère les rapports de
renseignement de la direction du
technique qui récupère les rapports qui
sont ramenés par nos partenaires
étrangers des rapports fournis par la
cia le mi6 la nsa et de tout cet
ensemble de renseignements bruts ils en
font une analyse et ensuite ils
construisent et donc voilà donc à la
dgse on a du brut mais ce qui est
transmis aux autorités politiques c'est
un renseignement élaboré analyser avec
une perte interpréter interpréter le
moins possible parce qu'on s'appuie
toujours une note secrète de la dgse si
elle n'a pas dû renseignement avant
précis de dents des chiffes des noms des
faits qui ont été vérifiés plusieurs
fois recouper c'est une mauvaise note
donc à chaque fois ces deux documents
qui sont qui sont le plus précis
possible avec des faits est ce qu'il ya
de l'eau tous sont sûrs
c'est-à-dire votre chef il a pas envie
d'entendre que ça va cramer parce que
vous comprenez son propre chef il a des
responsabilités politiques est ce qu'il
ya de l'autocensure dans la remontée
d'informations brutes moi
personnellement j'en ai pas eu mais je
me souviens sur la côte d'ivoire 2
d'entendre des gens qui étaient alors
c'est bien aussi non pardon aux ondes au
rwanda peut-être mais c'est et j'étais
pas encore au service à ce moment là gt
gt un effort spécial à bayonne
après d'ailleurs mais donc j'ai entendu
parfois où il des collègues se plaint de
dire tiens j'ai une position différente
de mon chef direct et donc j'ai pas peut
ne pas pu l'exprimer et donc ça arrive
un peu d'auto censure parfois peut-être
c'est dangereux c'est dangereux
normalement il faut l'éviter c'est ce
qui a fait que là bas la cia pour la
une guerre du golfe bien ils ont ils ont
transmis du faux renseignements enfin ou
du faux du renseignement fougue analysé
en partie faux il y avait des choses
faute et inventé en plus ancré en saas
rentrer dans le détail on gravissait les
tailles ou pas du tout son portrait
c'est ça qui m'intéresse donc
ça fait partie d'une séquence je pense
que ça a aidé le président chirac et
puis et puis toute la bronca française
ne pas suivre le partenaire américain
parce que là je pense que en
l'occurrence la dgse a très bien fait
son travail et je me souviens avoir vu
passer une note on fout pas que je
rentre trop dans le détail c'est une
autre note secret défense évidemment
mais mais elle est dans le sens de
l'histoire c'est que le le rapport
l'intervention de collines powell on a
fait remonter nos autorités politiques
que c'était bidon et bien voilà et puis
on a fait une note extrêmement précises
dans ça c'est faux ça c'est faux voilà
ça pourquoi on a amené des photos des
photos satellites on a démonté
complètement les choses en disant c'est
pas c'est peut-être vrai mais ça c'est
faux ça c'est faux ça c'est les fourrés
sim et donc on a fait remonter un
document extrêmement précis et qui
disait attention c'est du flan donc moi
les autorités politiques françaises à ce
moment là disaient d'accord laissons
nous ne laissons pas embarquer avec les
américains parce que là ils se
fourvoient
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'arabie
saoudite et les schizophrénies française
on a ce qui nous la schizophrénie
diplomatique française à traiter qu
l'arabie saoudite
alors bon là je vais parler
personnellement
donc je m'engage je vais d'abord enfin
je suis retraité de la dgse donc je
n'engage pas pour 2010 est depuis 2007
et 2017 donc je n'engage que moi et puis
c'est du passé un petit peu mais je vois
que ça continue
j'ai été en poste dans un pays du
moyen-orient qui traitait beaucoup de la
crise en syrie
et là je voyais bien que notre position
et je voyais le ballet diplomatique je
voyais le ministre des affaires
étrangères qui se déplaçait qu'ils aient
des discours dans le pays hôte dans
lequel j'étais et c'était dct c'était la
voix de l'arabie saoudite ont
s'alignaient on s'aligner sur l'arabe et
ce qui était évidemment c'est gênant sur
les états unis et donc sur les états
unis binôme moyen-orient ont fait ils
vont assez main dans la main ils sont
assez d'accord
d'un autre côté la guerre elle est aussi
économique et du coup mais cette
position là on a on a enfin commencé à
vendre nos futurs rafale donc est ce que
est ce que est ce que finalement c'est
pas de la realpolitik et cpas que est-ce
que c'était un mauvais choix ce que vous
entendez par réelle politique ces
politiques d'opportuniste mais c'est à
dire que la guerre économique
d'un pays sa puissance sa première
puisqu'elle provient d'économies dont il
faut faire baisser le poids du chômage
il faut faire grimper notre croissance
et donc faut pas faire un grand écart
abominable je pense que donc moi j'ai vu
des démonstrations effectivement qui
m'ont choqué parce qu on salit et trop
sur l'arabie saoudite
voilà mais donc il faut trouver le juste
milieu
la tempérance way est ce que vous
trouvez nos politiques ton père et
moi presse à ses opinions personnelles
s'aimer pincé un an noncé ça on va
entendre en tant que militaire on n'aime
pas parler nous obtenions peu de la
grande muette
la grande muette ouais il faudrait
grande castrés en ce moment
un no comment pourquoi nos communes de
la grande casse très chaud pas ce tome
on n'a plus la capacité d'avoir nommé
technologie nucléaire là maintenant
c'est plus la grande muette ça s'appelle
la grande castrés non c'est à dire que
heureusement on a une armée qui est aux
ordres du pouvoir politique aux ordres
de l'état français lors du peuple
français et que le pouvoir public entre
le protège son armée
jusqu'à un certain point oui je me suis
pas sentie complètement attaqué du temps
du temps de chirac par exemple les
budgets étaient
était très très bel ippon à protéger ce
fut l'époque donc là où on avait un
président qui aimait son armée avec une
il avait bien mis en place et mise la
défense qui aimait son armée est donc
bon ben voila mais
oui je me sens je me sens plutôt plutôt
protégé par le pouvoir politique par
exemple à l'aide des gse toujours des
budgets les budgets qui sont qui sont
protégés ont fait on fait des économies
on doit faire beaucoup d'économies comme
quoi le budget le dgs lui moi je les
partage ou pas bon là dessus pochette
voit même pas non il faut demander votre
communauté c'est déjà quelque chose
demande voilà qu'elle
dont il est il est très élevé notamment
c'est le renseignement alors seulement
techniques et coûte très cher que les
capacités d'interception la crypto
face à coacher le renseignement est mal
luné coûte pas très cher un jour on a
discuté avec un mec très sulfureux
s'appelait jacques vergès
et
il nous a dit
la france est devenue la [__] des
américains est-ce que vous conseiller
ses paroles
bon j'espère que non j'espère que non
on n'est pas dupe non plus on n'est pas
complètement naïf j'ai vu entendu pas
naïfs c'est à dire se dire oui à lille
est tout temps des états unis on y va on
les suit
la première puissance mondiale quoi on
paye on les paye ont une opel océans et
nous paye quoi le budget la cotisation
de l'otan il nous donne des avions
ravitailleurs uche pas et nous il nous
faut dix luton du renseignement anr il
nous donne pas du renseignement les
échanges de renseignements c'est ça
ouais mais ensuite après peut-être que
le dz l'échangé est illégal inégal je
veux dire pas illégal il peut être aussi
légal mais forcément
mais peut-être que les charges et
inégale donc il nous donne peut-être
plus con ce qu'on leur donne je ne sais
pas avait donc oui enfin moi j'espère
mais je pense que nos politiques ne sont
pas dupes et qu'on essaye de garder de
garder notre indépendance fin l'histoire
récente nous a montré qu'on savait aussi
dire stop aux américains il ya donc là
vous faites vous fourvoyez des exemples
soif la guerre en irak la guerre en irak
mais oui c'est la grosse grêle te lis
pas un nom de quoi de villepin oui c'est
ça oui ça tant que ça commence le pays
qui accueille ce continent qui a connu
la guerre et un ce cas rien de mauvais
les très belles tirades et des très
beaux discours
mais même récemment on sent que sur la
question iranienne
sur savoir disque faut-il faut-il avoir
une voix une position ferme et dur avec
l'iran ou faut-il essayé d'inclure
l'iran et la faire aller dans le sens de
la comédie international et je pense que
la la la la voix de la france est un peu
différent de celle des américains et
donc on joue notre carte moi je pense
qu'on a une certaine heureusement une
certaine indépendance donc là je vais
être gentil avec vous à parce que vous
savez qu'après je vais très méchante
d'accord bah oui c'est ce soir le cas
dans un interrogatoire on essaie d'être
gentil donc on se ramollit et paf
ensuite c'est la claque et c'est la
tartine c'est là qu'on craque donc la
communauté d'entrain préparer les
tartines d'accord
je vais vous poser des questions
directes ouais
quel tartine voulait en premier donc les
tartines c'est négatif c'est les bases
et les structures dire que c'est négatif
s'est négativement casser les reins de
janvier là c'est cette gentille ont dû
gentilles vous je sais pas moi laisse
aujourd'hui je veux que ça soit des
surprises dont je veux pas d'un jeu pas
orienté attendait cédric villani qui
nous passe un coup de fil on rappellera
celle
dont je veux pas de surprise une tartine
surprise une tartine surprise celle qui
réveillé d'un coup je sais pas c'est
gentil donc ça vaut pas forcément
réveiller force a donc je vais vous
endormir un petit peu avant voilà je me
prépare au pire après on va vous parler
füle vie privée
ça c'est interdit de gentil
trop gentil c'est pourquoi vous aimez
pas trop j'ai toujours été quelqu'un de
l'ombre et puis voilà on voit pas mon
visage tant qu'un ma vie privée est-ce
que vous utilisez un vpn pour y plaider
vos vidéos sur votre chaîne youtube n'en
n'ont que vous êtes un gros touristes un
gros thooris encourager c'est à dire en
et ancien de la dgse
je veux plaider vous vidéo de chez vous
est ce qu'on parle vie privée ça vous
vous êtes tombé aujourd'hui nous voilà
oui ça vous avez une tradition de
hacking est fort là dessus et donc oui
mon mât je suis en position fragilisée
maintenant je suis à la retraite les
savez il ya
c'est soit on est souvent cible de
tentatives de recrutement c'est les
têtes blanches on appelle ça des gens
récemment recruté récemment retraité
qui encore qui en sont encore proches de
la du service dans lequel qui viennent
de quitter ils connaissent les
procédures connaissent les gens qui sont
en place donc ils ont encore des
connaissances vivace et est utile si
elle cherchait boutons précédent ouais
je voulais dire et pourtant et pourtant
je suis fragilisé parce que j'ai plus de
services de sécurité qui me défends et
qui vient problème ça de lâcher les
anciens agents de la nature ça peut
l'être ça peut l'être alors après ils
ont ils sont bien formés ils ont des
réflexes et rendent compte sont
patriotes ils sont patriotes vous
actuellement ah oui comment ça se fait
qu'il ya un cadre de la dgse qui s'est
fait recruter par les chinois ah ben ça
ça arrive tous les services du monde ont
des traîtres ont des gens qu'on flanché
et c'est la beauté du jeu c'est à dire
que même quelqu'un qu'on a l'impression
qu'ils aient pas regrettable quand on
fait bien son travail on arrive on
arrive à recruter
moi je j'espère dit très difficilement
traitable puis plus les années passent
moi ce sera intéressant de le recruter
c'est maintenant on va déjà c'est un peu
trop tard
qui cherchez vous tous at on pu lire
récemment alors c'était ils sont
parvenus là parce que je crois que j'en
ai reparlé j'en ai dû en parler dans un
et rendez vous dans des interviews donc
j'ai eu un russe qui m'a contacté en
disant un jour qui se présentait comme
un journaliste m'a fait un long mail et
en disant bon
vous pouvez ce sera off
raconter des choses un peu secrète mais
mais c'était donc jugé tout de suite
signalé mon ancien services de sécurité
et puis ensuite j'ai eu un visiblement
un agent du mossad qui avait une
approche plus plus original qui voulait
me faire gagner beaucoup d'argent
lui-même se lancer comme quoi c'est quoi
beaucoup il ne disait pas mais disait
beaucoup voilà beaucoup et donc il est
un travail pour un riche mécène et il
avait besoin d'accès des archives et
comme j'étais un ancien qui pouvaient
avoir accès à certaines archives mais
ouverte il s'était pas encore du
renseignement en france santé c'était le
début de la proche et qui me testait sur
sur l'argent
c'était pas c'était bizarre c'était un
peu lourdingue et savait pas si tu es un
test de votre ancienne maison où c'était
réellement une projet non je pense pas
que le service s'amuse à faire des tests
il perdrait du temps et c'est de faire
des tests 28
mais ça pourrait pourquoi pas mais
annoncer ces choses je ne pense qu'ils
n'arrivent pas alors peut-être qu'après
alors attention enfin il va pas le faire
a priori mais ensuite si c'était un coup
le service de sécurité a un doute à mon
égard non merci cela un doute à mon
égard là il va peut-être se déroule à
lui on a un doute il est rase il ya des
contacts bizarre et dont il ne me parle
pas et donc là ils vont peut-être me
tester monter une opération et voir
comment je réagis en direct sont ça ça
peut arriver pourquoi pas mais de le
faire comme sa sortie de rien non je
pense qu'il a autre chose à faire aussi
lui aussi vous avez respecté la
procédure
c'est à dire prévenir la maison pas
voilà c'est ça oui absolument
et donc moi je pense que c'est difficile
de recruter un agent de la dgse à
l'étranger on est on est très bien payé
on est allés manger au canada pardon
quemada au canada enfin les approches
dont j'ai fait l'objet j'étais au canada
à ce moment là mais je dis c'est
difficile de recruter un agent de la
dgse
quand il est en poste à l'étranger donc
là dans les zones de crise parce que
notamment nos salaires sont alignés sur
ceux de ceux des diplomates et donc on
est bien payé 12 d orgueil par mois
pardon 12000 ouais ça peut être plus
sur des zones de crise difficile bien
entendu on grimpe ou wii influence et ça
c'est terrible on enfin c'est terrible
tant mieux ans j'en ai profité j'en suis
très content mais c'était très bien payé
hors impôts parce que parce qu'on n'a
pas la sécurité de ceux ci enfin si on a
un peu la conséquence de cela mais
disons on ne bénéficie pas des
infrastructures du pays donc on ya une
certaine unification pourquoi est-ce
qu'on paye moins d'impôts quand on est à
l'étranger c'est une certaine logique et
donc du coup on est bien payé et si un
service et celle de ne recruter il
faudrait qu'il mettre la barre très
haute et puis en plus bon les patriotes
je pense que la très grande majorité des
officiers de renseignement ce soit en
français ou dans les autres pays c'est
toujours difficile à recruter parce
qu'on aime son pays on sait on se démène
pour son pays
vous avez fait votre chaîne youtube en
2010 est juste après quatre mois après
votre mise à la retraite serait
49 ans et tout pour partir oui c'est un
choix c'est un choix
marc séné je crois au départ j'avais
deux femmes dont jeudi va revenir avec
deux enfants
vous donnez des coups trop de pistes
maison dont j'ai divorcé une première
fois et je me dis c'est pas la peine d'y
voir c'est une deuxième fois
c'est qu'elle a une vie particulière la
dgse donc cesser prenons on y pense tout
le temps on débranche pas
on est déployé dans les zones sensibles
déficit l'on reçoit la pression des
services locaux on traite de matières
difficiles donc c'est stressant et puis
on peut pas dire ce qu'on fait on n'a
pas de vie sociale c'est fatiguant à la
longue et donc donc au bout d'un moment
se dit tiens si on puces sont refait une
deuxième famille on vous tiens
j'aimerais bien voir mes enfants pas
plus souvent par exemple et dont c'est
le choix de faire de pour pour ma femme
actuelle de dire en tulle ouais je
devrais dire qu'il y en aura peut-être
une troisième sur sa non maintenant on
va moi j'espère s'arrêter là c'est le
but c'est le but du choix initial qui
est de débrancher d'arrêter de faire
autre chose
on y arrive c'est à dire oui
très étonnamment c'était c'était un
choix réfléchi j'avais pris la décision
en amont et donc j'avais dit à ma femme
après après le démon dernier poste
j'arrête elle ne croyait pas elle même à
médine on n'y arrivera pas donc moi
j'avais pris ma décision je suis parti
et puis ensuite je suis parti donc au
canada maintenant je peux le dire enfin
si peu donc on peut me chercher là bas
c'est pas là je me trouve mais je me
suis aperçu que en débranchant ben ça y
est on débranche le fils de lénine et on
a plus de réunions et c'est plus dans
l'urgence et finalement est bien
certaine un bien-être s'installer on
n'est pas c'est pas désagréable donc
j'ai apprécié ça ne m'a pas manqué et ça
va pas manquer aussi grâce à l'activité
que je refais maintenant c'est à dire
que je refais du renseignement entre
guillemets en en parlant avec une
communauté qui répond
québécois pq monde connecté avec une
mode connecté maintenant ce que je puis
le secret un cachet donc je peux
vraiment besoin de connecter et je me
suis pour la première fois en 2010 est
inscrit sur facebook et j'ai découvert
ces réseaux sociaux donc je m'étais
interdit c'est une nouvelle vie
formidable facebook on s'en passe très
bien
on va parler
l'opération secrète en afrique on va
revenir au premier sujet c'est pas ma
zone de prédilection mais bretonne de
prédilection séquences et l'asie du sud
est moi j'ai fait j'ai fait un feu asie
du sud est et puis et puis afrique
subsaharienne et moyen-orient donc
l'afrique bof vous était un bouffon
non je parle à peu quelques éditos
d'arhab au nord
puis chams al-yaoum m'affiche absalon
chouchou balzac voilà je joue le thème
du coup notamment coulter ma femme et à
ma famille à amiens et donc voilà des
petites formules pour me rendre
sympathique et ça va pas au-delà donc
celle m anna absolem mais
ça veut dire je suis absolument d'accord
trêve et salam
salam la paix mais bon arabe salam je ne
sais pas trop l'homme de paix l'homme de
paix très bien hab sens qu'elle alors
c'est génial ex1 c'est du dialecte
égyptien du sud je suis d'accord donc
moi je suis plutôt serein libanais
mais voilà donc mon niveau que nous
donc mon niveau d'arabes est très
basique mais ça m'a pas gêné dans ma
carrière donc on a on a des linguistes
et spécialistes qui parlent très bien
arables qui peuvent qu un niveau
suffisant pour traiter leur source en
arabe donc moi j'avais des sources que
je devais traiter en arabe j'avais un
interprète
voilà donc ça m'a pas gêné les opex que
vous avez réalisé ces ou encore audi
opex a fait plutôt armes armée classique
donc c'est pas dgse c'est pas c'est pas
un vocabulaire dgse drm faire des drm la
drm fait des opex auprès des directions
du recensement militaire donc ce c'est
le renseignement plus tactique c'est
moins du renseignement stratégique et et
ils sont déployés là où les armées
françaises sont déployées donc il occupe
un spectre que un que normalement la
dgse est moins forte là dessus donc
chacun chacun a sa zone pour travailler
mais parfois on s'aperçoit que ça se
mange un petit peu sur les pieds comme
revenons à votre clandestinité ouais
c'était ou alors mais opex c'est ça
ouais donc mais clandestinité que ça
veut dire quoi opérations extérieures on
a donc joué j'en ai fait un version
extérieure quand j'étais militaire aux
premières pma donc régiment parachutiste
forces spéciales bayonne
groupe un jus tice de strasbourg vous
les connaissez le dragon page c'est quoi
c'est pas hyper justice à strasbourg où
elle était à dieuze non voilà donc ils
sont redescendus maintenant depuis
quelques années ils sont où est-ce
qu'ils sont maintenant je positions dans
le sud maintenant ils sont ils sont
revenus au soleil et ils sont rapprochés
du commandement des opérations spéciales
qui est à pau voilà donc ils sont plus
dans le nord est ces sommes pareilles
castelnaudary c'est ou parle oui au
village oui mais bon cassoulet est un
très beau régiment parachutiste
d'infanterie de marine
et donc autant que j'ai fait les opex en
bosnie en bosnie et puis
fui des opérations de garde près de
formation de gardes présidentielles en
afrique mais donc voilà ça c'est bien et
puis j'en ai j'ai fait une opex au
sud-liban également à la finul sur la
frontière libano-israélienne
ça c'est les opex ensuite je fais des
opérations donc j'ai été projeté
plusieurs fois dans des opérations plus
courtes
clandestine sous fausse identité
faux passeport photo fausse valence
humilité non non c'est plus difficile et
sa chanteuse belge mais bon on peut tuer
les hommes si nous on paie dessus on n'a
pas l'accent un peu gênant
c'est comme ça tout mouillé nous ça fait
rapidement pieds nickelés ça commence à
laisser d'avoir un accent belge ou
suisse si on rencontre des suisses et
des belges vont venir mais fait quoi toi
c'est quoi ton fils et le monde ça se
rend compte facilement non
donc nord donc on reste français on
reste france heures la légende pour
qu'elle fonctionne et faut qu'elle soit
au plus proche de la réalité de qui on
est vraiment
c'est quoi la légende pour les
aficionados qui ne connaissent pas le
bureau des légendes eh bien on veut
cacher parfois pour pouvoir atteindre
nos sources quand on va résumer ça votre
mito qui vous entourent et qui vous
protège votre fausse identité ouais ça
on vous passera dans tes en ailleurs
bonjour on le dg ce je m'appelle bay 114
agent de la dgse est ce que vous voulez
parler avec moi si vous acceptez devenu
une source donc ça marche pas les gens
vont se cabrer donc il vaut mieux
arriver en nous avons jours les
journalistes tel journal je suis
humanitaire c'est les grands classiques
où je suis
je suis responsable je suis un
scientifique de haut niveau et c'est
donc en crème les gens qui va nous
permettre d'approcher des gens sans la
faire peur et donc avec un faux nom
évidemment et puis ça si ça tourne mal
l'intérêt de la légende c'est qu'elle se
démonter qu'elles ne remontent à rien
donc on elle remonte pas sur l'état
français donc on peut se cacher et puis
on peut disparaître du jour au lendemain
vous parlez de légende de journalistes
et vous parlez de légende d'humanitaires
est ce que vous pensez pas que les
services secrets une plombé le travail
des journalistes et ont plombé le
travail des humanitaires parce que à
force de se cacher comme des débutants
ou d'accord alors rappelé non mais on
est d'accord moi je vais je vais jouer
la provoc je veux pas la provoc j'aurai
la provoque en moi je ne prétends pas à
les faire pousser des plantes anti
paludisme en plein désert
le mec qui a inventé cette légende c'est
un touriste c'est quoi bon après il y
avait parfois des travail qu'on était
mal fait je ne vois pas tellement à
bâcler oui bâclé ou dit
parfois des légendes on était mal monté
et c'est pas du travail professionnel et
donc ça c'est condamnable mais mais je
comprends ça c'est un vrai débat et est
d'ailleurs maintenant les terroristes
refuser les convois humanitaires et
refuse les journalistes ou prétexte que
ce sont des agents
ça pose un vrai problème et j'ai des
camarades
humanitaires et journalistes qui disent
vous ne vous ne faisiez notre travail
alors après ce pouvoir l'échelle qu'elle
s'est fait il ya camélia les
humanitaires ils sont à 99% à manille
taire les journalistes sont 99 % des
vrais journalistes
se discute ça c'est est ce que c'est un
autre débat mais voilà donc je pense que
je pense que on essaye et puis en plus
quand on fait vivre sa légende on essaie
d'être un bon humanitaire et un bon
journaliste donc on essaye de bien faire
son travail de journaliste bien faire
son travail humanitaire dont c'est qu'on
ait le temps de l'es2 les gens c'est
quoi le travail d'un bon journaliste
c'est de faire remonter une
véritable information de faire remonter
des alertes faire de remonter la réalité
de ce qui se passe sur le terrain pour
informer le plus grand nombre nous
semble-t-il
connaissez la charte de munich oui oui
on m'a dit que vous étiez très à cheval
sur enfin vous faisait référence souvent
c'est qui
je ne citerai pas ma source et
d'ailleurs je vous dis la fosse iliaque
une source c'est même pas recoupé je les
initie à non c'est pas le nom donc là
j'aurais pu recouper avec des nas et
on a reçu récemment
un monsieur très gentil qui s'appelle
maxime renahy qui était une de vos deux
vous source oms pour faire de
l'espionnage économique
pour la france
alors on dit agent de la dgse on dit
quoi quelle est la différence entre
agents honorable contributes
où est ce que je vous dis ouais je vois
je moi je suis pas très bon sur les
solides termes et définitions c'est
souvent je m'égare maintenant moi même
je vais utiliser le terme d' espions ou
d'agents alors qu'on dit maintenant
l'agencé vous le titrez pensez-vous donc
parfois moi même je me trompe de
vocables parce que ce qui se cache
derrière les mots
limite m'intéresse moins que la réalité
que ça recouvre véritablement bon en
tout cas il ya l'officier traitant c'est
clairement le fonctionnaires de la dgse
la source la source avait un agent
effectivement donc cet invité très
sympathique qui a fait du renseignement
pour son pays pour le service ils
étaient ils étaient est une source il
était un agent et un honorable
correspondant il va le faire
gratuitement il est franc c'est et il va
rendre service actuellement va pas faire
un travail de source mais il va nous
aider
facilité
donnée des locaux de couverture des
trajets en avion un accès il va nous
faciliter un contact il retient voulait
rencontrer là d'un tel un tel individu
moi je le connais je peux vous faire je
vous le présenter dans un cocktail l'air
de rien voilà ça c'est un travail de nos
honorables correspondants qui va rendre
service et un essai très important les
anglais le font systématiquement le font
mieux peut-être que les français mais
nous on a la dgse a énormément de
contributeurs qui font ça gratuitement
pour leur pays et ça nous ça nous
facilite la vie grandement donc plus on
a de nora corresponde bien connecté bien
placé qui veulent nous aider mieux ça
alors votre source nous a fait remonter
de l'information
j'ai pas lu complètement la vidéo met
donc je suis pas gravement le résultat
met au parfum
son officier traitant
[Musique]
lui lui a demandé de se renseigner sur
la stabilité des banques
et sa conclusion c'était la dg
souhaiterait stressé par rapport à la
stabilité du système financier
c'est normal que la dgse s'intéresse à
ça c'est une commande c'est une commande
personnel c'est le chef de service et le
pouvoir politique a demandé c'est
quelqu'un de plus intelligent dans le dg
ce qui est un cousin à quelqu'un qui
réagit enfin fait la prospective le
renseignement économique à la dgse il
est encore c'est une couche de secret
supplémentaires c'est très sensible
évidemment c'est rapidement illégal
encore plus son façon on travaille
souvent dans l'illégalité dans ce métier
même au profit au profit de la
collectivité de l'état met donc le
renseignement économique s'est encore
encore plus secret donc c'est des gens
qui
qui mélangent pas leur bureau ils sont
dans un étage où on va moins souvent et
il nous parle moins que d'autres à la
cafétéria où on échange quelques petits
secrets et c'est ce qu'ils font durer
seulement économique parle-moi leurs
petits camarades donc donc je n'ai pas
fait de renseignement économique enfin
je ne sais pas je n'ai pas travaillé
dans l'intérieur de ce secteur du
service j'ai fait quand je suis déployés
en poste à l'extérieur on répond à
toutes les a tout laissé tous les
secteurs du service à la centrale
boulevard mortier donc du coup quand on
est en poste à l'extérieur on fait un
peu d'enseignements économique mais mais
voilà ça ne va pas au delà donc je
connais un peu de renseignements
économiques mais c'est hier qu'on nous
pose des questions
et donc on nous dit tiens là et on a
telle entreprise française qui qui veut
remporter un marché il ya deux
concurrents essayé d'en savoir plus par
exemple ici non seulement plus c'est à
dire essayer de savoir les propositions
qu'ils ont fait par exemple bien sûr
je vais juste me tarde d un peu sur les
histoires cafétéria les le côté un peu
plus prétentieux des agents de
renseignements économiques
potentielles fortement s'est vu l'état
de la france vu l'état de la france vous
allez me dire bon ils ont tellement de
bien travailler c'est à cause d'eux cons
et qu'on en est là c'est ça pourrait
être pire sa ligne de défense classique
et est ce que vous pensez pas qu'ils
sont un peu gratter les couilles vu
l'état de la situation économique
française
vu comment s'est fait défoncer alstom vu
comment s'est fait défoncer technip vu
comment s'est fait défoncer bnp vu
comment on s'est fait défoncer la
société générale et ma liste ils ont
comme le bras on peut pas c'est facile
aussi de se retourner sur le sol
renseignements le salami seul seul
service de renseignement il parle est
montrable données sur le politique
pardon il faut se retourner sûr qu'ils
voient ce que c'est un jour l'outil va
falloir demander des comptes ouais qui
contrôle la dgse qui contrôle la
performance de ses agents qui contrôlent
leurs résultats
les a beaucoup de questions donc prendre
le temps ouais ça on peut prendre le
temps anciennement économique
qui quelles sont les erreurs qui ont été
faites
bon j'ai été responsable d'asie du sud
est
et de la chine je vous laisse vous
laisse vous lancelin faut donc un petit
peu sur le renseignement sur la chine
donc la chine pas très bon service de
renseignement extérieur parce qu'ils se
focalisent sur les cinq parfums qui sont
leurs menaces internes donc ils sont pas
très bons renseignements internationaux
là où ils sont très bons c'est très bien
c'est qu'ils ont cédé à coeur c'est avec
énormément de moyens des moyens
techniques et puis il se pose pas de
question et hippie hippie hippie et et
ça donne du résultat ça soit technique
ou humain et ils ont que j'ai vu des
grandes entreprises françaises
je citerai pas et qui font ce calcul là
qu'ils savent qu'ils vont être payés un
peu qu'ils décident de faire des
contrats et de développer leur expertise
en chine notamment ils savent qu'ils
vont se faire piquer un petit peu ils
l'acceptent mais c'est le pari c'est se
dire on va développer à court terme on
va pouvoir avoir développé des marchés
donc dont donc on va faire marcher la
croissance et ont fait le pari que de
toute façon une recherche développement
qui va tellement plus vite même si nos
copies ce conte ce qu'on s'est fait déjà
fait on aura un temps d'avancé le pari
qui est dangereux et peut être on se
plante et peut-être qu'à terme tandis 20
ans on se mordront s'en mordra les
doigts leur qu'irresponsable là dedans
est tout le monde essaie de faire son
boulot l'heure l'entreprise et les
seuils de pas trop s'est replié c'est
les décisions de chefs d'entreprise qui
disent bon là on n'a pas de but on n'a
pas de budget ça va mal c'est la crise
il faut des débouchés donc il faut
accepter et donc c'était
ouais c'est dé paris c'est les choix qui
responsable poumon un petit peu quand
même mais d'accord après évidemment ça
ne rien dire la veille on pense car de
ram ouais non on se parle entre un
brevet n'avait bien sûr c'est le but
mais ensuite après qu'il ya des erreurs
manifestes mais faut remonter tirer
tirer les conclusions et est sanctionné
s'il faut moi j'ai la dgse c'est un
service on sanctionne un camp c'est
quand c'est raté c'est un petit service
sait pas on n'est pas nombreux c'est pas
là c'est pas la cia s'est pas c'est pas
170 mille personnes on n'arrive pas à
identifier la compétence vous tombez pas
dans le misérabilisme de l'impuissance
non ce n'est pas elle c'est pas le but
mais donc c'était une petite structure
donc les incompétents les connaît et
donc on identifie et puis on les vire et
puis on vivre ça on vire très souvent à
cc ont fait pas des carrières très
longue ads parce qu'on est souvent viré
donc alors après il ya des exceptions et
les gens qui dure on sait qu'ils sont
mauvais mais on les laisse comme vous
nous cachez ces cartes et non je pense
que j'étais bon acheter pas mal comme
vous avez fait pour durer aussi
longtemps mais où donc on sait pas non
plus ok corral donc on n'est pas non
plus gérer à tour de bord mais donc j'ai
aimé mon travail j'ai toujours fait des
défis différents donc moi je me suis
passionné j'ai à chaque fois rebondi
fédé fait des challenges importants je
changeais de dossiers change est plus
problématique de thématiques de région
donc c'est pour ça que enfin voila je
suis resté parce que j'ai toujours
trouvé un intérêt à rester aussi
longtemps et puis j'ai pas fait
d'erreurs majeures
c'était que vous êtes
ben
j'ai un peu cette méthode anglo saxon de
ne pas cacher mes erreurs
et donc
j'avais fait des erreurs dans un poste
extérieur et je les ai raconté en amphi
aux jeunes officiers traitants qu'elle
est partie en poste extérieur et les
gens disent à wau c'est passionnant il
raconte ses erreurs et comment est-ce
qu'il a réagi comment et c'est important
d'accepter de ne pas cacher ses erreurs
ce qu'on a tendance aussi dans un
service aussi secret kdg ce à quoi zone
et a pas trop communiquer et puis ce qui
a été ratée de pas trop de les chefs ça
mais en bas on sait pas moi je pense
qu'il faut communiquer sur les erreurs
les échecs les assumer voilà là j'ai
bien réagi là j'ai raté complètement
pour telle ou telle raison je me suis
fait avoir mais j'ai bien réagi après
j'ai fait ça ça c'est raté mais ça
c'était très réussi voilà donc il faut
il faut parler il faut il faut parler de
ses échecs pour grandir et s'améliorer
il faut polir sapiens c'est ça ouais
qu'est ce que
qui vous met les chefs qu'est ce qui
positionne au chef c'est au mérite c'est
le politique je me fais l'avocat du
diable way qui vous met vos chefs ils
sont à chaque prise ça dépend le niveau
donc chaque et directeur chaque
président ça change
comment ça se passe donc c'est
ça y est le directeur général et puis à
5 directions avec cinq directeurs donc
les quand on arrive au niveau directeur
ccc nommé en jetait pas dire pas niveau
directement on sait que des mois j'ai
des colonels donc je directeur j'avais
encore une règle je reste plus longtemps
pour pouvoir aspirer peut-être à devenir
directeur de la dgse ce qui était encore
possible
mais dont voilà les directeurs ils sont
nommés en conseil des ministres donc
cédé poste éminemment politique
évidemment est donc celle politique
issue qui choisit
actuellement on a on a comme directeur
du renseignement un homme du cru donc a
fait toute sa carrière au sein des dons
c'est un véritable expert du
renseignement donc évidemment c'est
aussi un politique sans doute parce que
s'il a été il était gardé la pardon donc
encartés en cartouche pas jusque là mais
c'est ça il faut il faut quand même que
le pouvoir politique il est confiance
aux hommes qu'ils aient mis dans alors
çà çà çà des risques aussi un peut-être
effectivement de d'entendre ce qu'on
veut entendre c'est celle risque mais il
est important aussi
on travaille pour le pouvoir politique
pour un homme politique pour un
président et il faut que le président
ait confiance en ses services non ça
marche pas
on ouvre une petite parenthèse
l'affairé alsthom comment ça se fait que
la dgse on a interviewé frédéric pierrot
çi je la connais pas de nommer vous
inquiétez pas dans l'univers venir mais
n'a gros comme une maison d'accord
on lui a posé la question si la dg soul
avait un petit peu épaulé formés sur les
attaques des concurrents sur les
dispositions qu'à l'étranger par exemple
on a connu un gars de chez vous qui
allez pris la présidence d'une société
en asie pour encaisser les les menaces
de la mafia locale pour éviter que le
réel patron passe
un sale quart d'heure est-ce que ça se
fait toujours de mettre des chefs
d'entreprise des services de
renseignement à la tête d'entreprises
françaises à l'étranger
je pas d'exemple en tête ça c'est
peut-être fait est-ce que c'est
intéressant est ce que c est ce qu'il
faut le faire quand c'est pas le rôle la
dgse de forme et de former des chefs
d'entreprises qui vont se faire attaquer
forme écrite heures on peut faire de qui
c'est plutôt la dgsi d'ailleurs mais
après je veux pas faire une passe passe
à l'aise mais alors j'ai ici
l'expérience à l'étranger tous annoncé
passant des livres ne servent à rien
c'est vrai il ya peut-être une
incohérence là dedans mais on participe
un petit peu à ça aussi on peut faire
des séances de sensibilisation aux
risques du renseignement économique du
pillage de des réflexes donc ça se fait
un peu ça pourrait se faire
systématiquement ça c'est un petit peu
donc je vous résume alston capacités
nucléaires connecter à notre armée
pas épauler pas encadré ce faisant
désossé ou nez à la barbe de tout
pouvoir politique
les services ils ont un petit peu parlé
chez vous c'était juste des petits bouts
de couloir il tourné la tête j'ai pas
j'étais plus dans j'étais plus dans le
secret des dieux à ce moment là ils
dansent dans ce jour je sais pas
exactement comment ça se fait ça c'est
quand même
c'est ça mais 2017 mais moi j'étais en
2017 je sors le parapluie mais en fait
parce que je ne sais pas donc en 2007
j'étais déjà en poste extérieur au
moyen-orient est jeune voilà ce qui se
passe à paris des grands thèmes moi
j'étais très concentré son masoni donc
j'avais déjà bien à faire j'avais mes
questions sur ma zone et quand on est
allé à l'extérieur à l'étranger on n'a
pas cette vision d'ensemble qu'on peut
avoir quand on est en poste à paris
voilà on en profite parce que vous êtes
là on sait que vous patron vous regarder
ce soir
j'espère qu'il ya autre chose à faire je
suis prêt mais de 50 euros sur la table
je pense qu'un certain qu'ils regardent
dans ma main
on en profite pour faire passer des
messages on a été très fâché que que la
france se fasse dépouillé alstom par les
américains
qu'est ce que vous pensez du fait que
les américains aient en france une
ambassade avec un toit qui est bardé
d'antennes en plein milieu de paris
quand on regarde nos ambassades dans le
monde entier on a aussi beaucoup
d'antennes
donc oui le oui c'est choquant oui c'est
énervant oui quand on en parle à nos
collègues de la dgsi ils savent ils
savent que les américains travaillent
beaucoup à paris il essaye de les
embêter nous empêcher de travailler
après on accepte qui travaillent un peu
peut-être attendez attendez oui ils les
embête comment
faut demander à la dgsi mais on met des
pv sur leur voiture ils font quoi ils
peuvent convoquer l'agent on dire voilà
ce qui s'est passé avec ce mode est non
quand on a appris que nous président
était écouté puis 3 les trois dernières
dans nature on a fait quoi on a fait
comme avec la sphère vladislav
l'admirent vetrov on a
expédié des cards diplomate avec un coup
de pied dans le cul
ou a fait quoi donc la dgsi amis des
petits pv sur les voitures c'est un nom
il ya eu il ya eu des discussion d'homme
à homme en disant à haut niveau entre
directeurs généraux numéro à nos
services de renseignement on s'est dit
les choses
vous êtes dit les choses façon oss 117
c'est à dire ils vous ont pris un peu de
haut ils ont un peu rougis ils ont fait
quoi est-ce qu'il fallait les prendre
par la peau du cul et leur dire
maintenant les gars vous foutez pas un
peu notre gueule c'est une option c'est
une option de faire comme comment on
fait ça comme on fait aux russes et aux
chinois où on va on va les expulser on a
pas on n'a pas choisi d'expulser alors
on n'a pas choisi cette expertise on n'a
pas choisi d'expulser un terrain parce
que c'est un allié malgré tout donc on
préfère essayer ou parce qu on est
aveugle sans eux
c'est toujours c'est le jeu des grandes
puissances du relations internationales
on a besoin aussi des temps détendez
vous avez dit quoi grandes puissances
ouais est ce que la france n'est pas
devenue une puissance de moyenne
puissance et oui c'est un c'est un autre
débat on est plus forts au sein de
l'europe je suis un européen convaincu
croyez l'europe de la défense on change
de sujet ça vous laisse respirer
oui je crois alors de défense je crois
moi l'europe du renseignement parce que
le renseignement c'est vraiment
spécifique aux intérêts des lettres de
l'état et les intérêts de la france sont
pas toujours concomitant avec avec les
intérêts de l'europe donc le
renseignement c'est vraiment celle
intime c'est le secret donc on partage
on a toujours du mal à le partager donc
on peut faire on peut partager du
renseignement contre terreau ça fait
tout le monde est d'accord là dessus
mais c'est pas ça donc je crois -
renseignements européens mais la défense
européenne oui et puis la puissance de
frappe économique européenne malgré tout
on a on a des budgets qu'on peut mal mal
utilisé mais des budgets qui sont quand
même fort quand on prend des décisions
fortes l'europe
l'europe l'espace airbus les grandes les
grandes réussites industrielles cédé
vraie réussite européenne auquel je
crois attention mettez pas jimmy bonneau
par terre
j'en ai fait est ce que vous voulez un
petit peu
un petit plein où ça va aller ça va
encore ça va encore on dans dix minutes
je viendrai faire le ravitaillement on a
on a nos internautes en direct qui nous
propose une petite diversion peut-il
nous parler de carlos ghosn
que dire de carlos ghosn moi je vois là
je m'en suis sortie
je vais raconter ça c'est pas mon
dossier c'est pas mon domaine donc je
vais raconter ce que je pense que
citoyen ça n'a pas vraiment d'intérêt
donc je botte en touche ou du joker geof
non j'ai rien de ces
tristes de voir un chef d'entreprise de
ce niveau-là tomber aussi bas l'histoire
à l'air complexe sympa quand elles sont
les fautes il ya des luttes d'influencé
entre intérêts japonais et français
ça avait l'air d'être un gros dépensiers
il ya eu des excès faire
je sais que ce que je vis dans les
journaux dans la presse donc je ne vais
pas de commentaire intelligent ou utiles
pour la communauté à faire je vais vous
proposer de faire un commentaire utile
on a une question d' exocet exocet du
pseudo avec un back flip à 182 et c'est
encore meilleur
quand sa question c'est aurions-nous les
cojones d'accueillir ce nous donne bah
ça y est on a répondu on a dit non on
n'a pas les cojones ça c'est le drion
saint louis moi je crois que je crois
que le drian et 6 10 as et qui sait que
ce qu'il a déjà l'opinion de la décision
du président le drian la fir karachi
comment il a laissé tomber certains
militaires font c'est bon c'est juste un
détail et donc voilà je pense qu'on
n'aura pas les coronas moi je trouve ça
manquerait pas de gueule d'accueillir ce
matin alors qu'on n'a pas les cojones de
le faire
je suis parvenue la [__] des
américains
voilà je pensais que vous avez
évidemment vous saisissez la balle au
bond pour essayer de un petit ce match
là tout de suite une petite tartine ou
cool attendez donc ce serait moi
j'aimerais rang tant que en tant que
citoyen français
est plus mal micro ah oui pardon
en tant que fonctionnaire français dans
en tant que citoyen français j'aurais
bien aimé quand on accueille loden je
pense que ça aurait de la gueule et un
sens et voilà parce que ce qu'il a
montré comment se faisait punir ou tri
par les services américains qui nous
traitaient comme des esclaves des va
souder [__] ou c'est parce que il faut
qu'on récupère nos plumes notre flegme
et nos de riou après saint nazaire ne
faut quand même ouvrir les yeux de leur
enseignement de masse de l'année ça on
le connaît on sait et puis on en fait
nous aussi tous les grands services
occidentaux
personne n'est surpris là dedans danone
vous faites du renseignement masque de
masse bien sûr ça vous fait du ramassage
scolaire
non noire la dgse et fait partie des
grands services occidentaux qui matent
beaucoup d'argent pour pouvoir écouter
les câbles sous main c'est un défi de
pouvoir stocker des extrêmes des grandes
quantités de données et de pouvoir les
fouilles et donc il faut des
scientifiques de haut niveau pour
pouvoir piocher et stocker des quantités
astronomiques de données et là c'est le
setter des défis de tous les grands
services tous les grands services de
renseignement
alors je sors du cadre
merci c'est du café c'est du café
adobe du coup j'ai perdu le fait la
belle en tir vu par le palan tirs
non
non non non or rafraîchissez mois la
mémoire non non d'accord question
suivante aux tartines au nom va presser
papale en tire je ne sais pas tout j'ai
débranché en 2010 alors revenons sur ce
nous donne ouais vous inquiétez pas en
2017 il était déjà positionné pour nous
donc ouais on ouvre des grands yeux et
ses danses et ses sites et c'était bien
de prendre conscience du problème du
c'est un débat de société savoir
jusqu'où on va s que c'est correct est
ce que c'est moral mais bon tous les
grands services occidentaux et non
occidentaux et chinois font on traite du
renseignement de masse
et donc oui on peut on peut crier à la
vierge effarouchée mais ça se fait on
s'est donc est ce qu'on fait du
renseignement sur les américains ça peut
nous arriver
du renseignement efficace bah oui sinon
c'est intéressant
c'est pour sa part ça ils sont un peu
c'est sensible ça et c'est donc là je
taquine le secret défense ne veut pas
dire
sus aux tons la tangente du secret on
vous écoute
vous savez il ya des choses qui sont
quand les amériques quand les américains
font du renseignement humain sur les sur
les allemands et qui recrute une source
moyenne un colonel de l'art du bnd qui
leur donne et documents secrets et qui
quand on regarde la qualité du
renseignement qui a été donné c'est
comme assez minable ses moyens c'est
durant seulement moyens et quand ça se
sait voilà on crée un
on crée un drame un psychodrame et on
agace profondément la chancelière et ont
créé un incident diplomatique qui ne
vaut pas la peine donc quand on fait du
renseignement trop agressif contre
malgré tout un allié
vous du renseignement agressif proactif
ou agressif c'est un peu les deux c'est
si on commence à essayer la djs je pense
pas que la dgse essaye de recruter à un
agent de la cia par exemple et je serais
surpris que la cia essaye de recruter un
agent de la dgse par exemple alors que
la cia face du renseignement technique
écoute l'elysée
bah oui et l'afld voilà j'ai eu mes
potes des cédantes il faut il faudrait
jamais peau des services qui est en
train de dire que vous êtes un gros
mytho un gros mytho d'accord qu'est ce
qui veut dire pour sa part là on va
attendre son deuxième essai mais ça
voilà je l'attends il peut m'expliquer
gros mytho continuer bref la bagasse et
celui là mais c'est très bien il faut il
faut faire face à ses contradicteurs
donc voilà sûr on faut pas être surpris
il faut se garder il faut savoir c'est
que des maximes de sécurité entre les
communications de nos gouvernants de nos
chefs d'entreprise en se disant oui on
sera écouté pas américain et oui c'est
notre menace principale parce que
techniquement c'est les meilleurs est ce
qu'on cherche à les intoxiqués
je pense oui ça peut nous arriver c'est
une partie de manière sereine quelle
bière ça serait bonne guerre alors pas
forcément n'a pas peut-être pas au
niveau d'un service de renseignement
mais je pense que airbus quand vous un
des grands groupes en des grands groupes
qui sont dans des négociations dures et
qui implique de gros contrats avec
beaucoup d'argent serait pas idiot à
leur niveau des toxiques et j'espère
qu'ils le feront
comment ça c'est leur guerre aussi alors
on peut les idées et leur proposer oui
j'ai plein d'idées
mais c'est pas un travail que je peux je
cherche à faire s'est pas engagée il ya
d'anciens d'anciens membres du service
qui pour leur retraite ou leur deuxième
carrière font carrière dans ton monde et
groupe
tous sont responsables la sécurité des
grands groupes et donc là ils peuvent
apporter leurs idées leur imagination
leur expertise et c'est peut-être utile
pour faire du renseignement économique
pourrait plus efficace et pour faire
gaffe à nous à les américains nous nos
amis américains qui n'hésitent pas à
vous en pousser quelques semaines
comment nous pouvons pousser
quelques-unes est
plus triviale non j'ai pas compris c'est
à dire quoi nous mettre des bananes sous
les pieds si vous voulez une expression
plus où nous l'a maintenu un profond
voilà ça c'est la vôtre c'est votre
expression je n'utiliserai pas c'est une
expression que les militaires qui nous
écouteront bien comprendre ben voilà on
est très bien comme ça c'est clair vous
avez été formé à quel type d'armes
d'armes
pistolet donc quand j'ai fait du jld et
j'étais donc forces spéciales encore
forces spéciales on appela d'armes
différentes on quand on aime on
n'utilise pas le famas qui était en
dotation plastique qui rouillent c'est
un oui oui un peu il ya un peu compliqué
ce n'était pas marrant suite il est très
précis et très précis ce soit parce
qu'elles sont faites les balles du famas
ou à ce qu'elle s'en fait ce sommet non
vous savez maintenant
je fais pas dans le sud de la france non
à pourquoi maintenant mais des balles
autant dans les dents les femmes à ce
qu'ils sont moins précises qui sont pas
faites à saint-etienne au score je vais
pas non
donc continuez look après voilà j'ai
souvent travaillé avec du hk donc le ht
hd si c'est ce détroit c'est une île et
souffre silencieux ou pas silencieux g
de 733 qui est un mc secours que
j'aimais bien très précis voilà ensuite
j'ai fait des séances de tir avec le
service action ou là j'ai tiré à plein
d'armes
puis désertique gueule de l'inspecteur
harry des fusions il fait beaucoup de
flamme ici c'est à pas grand chose c'est
énorme c'était flingue de l'armée
irakienne c'est ça non bon pourquoi pas
mais en tout cas en tout cas c'est ça
c'est une puissance d'arrêt folk et
qu'ils arrêtent un bus lancé à pleine
vitesse on se démonte l'épaule quand on
tire avec ce que ça pas grand intérêt
mais c'est une puissante voilà donc
c'est très ça représente très peu de ma
carrière c'est pas un officier traitant
un officier de renseignement il ya peu
le site irish usage de son arme s'il a
une arme on sait qu'il a mal fait son
travail qui est détectée et que ça se
passe mal pour lui
donc on tire peu
section aux sports de combat
j'en ai fait
j'en ai on a eu pour partir en poste où
j'étais en partie en poste j'étais fort
mais tous ceux qui partiront postes dans
les zones difficiles et on a eu une
heure de formation de sport de combat
qu'est ce qu'on fait en une heure de
sport de combat
aucun intérêt
l'instructeur étaient très intelligents
nous a fait passer deux idées fortes
nous a montré d'abord des des images
récupérées sur youtube des caméras de
surveillance il est et de gens qui a
attaqué qui frappent des vieilles dans
la rue ou des voyous qui frappe à mort
pratiquement des gens et qui se
précipitent se re une manière bestial
vous voyez si jamais vous êtes attaqué
une fois un jour
les gens ils sont là pour vous cartonnez
ils vont vous faire très mal ils vont
nous tuer peut-être ils vont et donc si
vous mettez pas assez à ce niveau de la
défense tout de suite vous allez rater
donc si jamais où là vous prenez la
fuite et on vous conseille mais si
jamais vous fait face à de la bestialité
de la violence sourde comme ça mettez
vous un très haut niveau et n'essayez
pas de pousser à vous frapper pour je
trouvais que en sensibilisation ça
prenait une demi-heure et c'est
extrêmement efficace deuxième idée que
nous et qui nous a expliqué il ya quand
vous avez quelqu'un avec un couteau ne
croyez pas que coûte au départ et avec
avec une clé de bras avec un bras et
c'est le couteau c'est une arme mortelle
autant qu'un pistolet vous êtes piqué
dans le vans vous en sortirez pas vous
allez vous répondre perdre votre sang
ils ont quand vous avez un am quelqu'un
qui sort un couteau si vous n'êtes pas à
ceinture noire de logis dessus mais vous
prenez la fuite parti très vite parce
que c'est très dangereux il dévoila
voilà la formation que j'ai eue c'était
très succinct j'ai eu d'autres
formations sports de combat quand
j'étais à forces spéciales mais à la
dgse c'est la seule que j'ai eu et je la
trouve très intelligente
voilà
en termes de
prévention de l'interrogatoire difficile
est ce que vous avez reçu une formation
à la torture oui plusieurs fois
donc vous voulez que je développe
on le fait dans la série on se fait dans
vous avez eu le coup des carrés de sucre
je pense que ça si je vous mets à genoux
sur deux qui arrive à faire mal au bout
d'un moment on n'a pas fait ça aurait
fait la baguette c'est quoi une petite
bague être assis sur les tétons un petit
peu non non ah ouais ça gratte et c'est
sa ferme alors on n'a pas fait ce qu'il
faut c'est excitant ouais donc on a
suivi quand j'étais forces spéciales à
bayonne sur les thèmes entre sur les
tétons c'était plus
d'accord
la française les viewers ne voit pas les
gestes qu'on fait en avant que cédera
donc on peut pas enlacer que ces cachets
donc je ne je ne détaille pas les
guêtres ainsi dans le cul non d'accord
non combat j'avais fait ça
m'est donc eu des entraînements très
poussées à la torture avec de la torture
physique qui fait mal
ce qui est intéressant c'est que les
gens quand ils ont monté ce cet
entraînement à la torture qui est très
bien fait monitorer par des médecins
donc on sait on va jamais trop loin
c'est vrai c'est très sérieux ils sont
allés voir avant de monter ce programme
tout ce qui était fait à l'extérieur par
les brésiliens des britanniques c'était
en termes d'entretien qui me les
américains peut-être je pas eu
d'histoire de tristan non ouais je pense
pas que ce soit allé voir les
pakistanais lui donner les noms le
libanais connais bien l'intention non
pas plus mais pas plus qu'un autre mais
un copain copain mais a donc je veux pas
terminer mon histoire sur la torture
c'est dommage non mais on a tout le
temps réussi donc
donc c'est formateur de forces spéciales
en sont allés voir les autres et on voit
que chacun réagit différemment selon sa
culture un brésilien quand on commence à
l'engueuler on crie du poisson pourri et
va se décomposer il pleure il n'aime pas
qu'on gueule qu'on vous fait ça un
français vous leur gré
rien à faire il ne réagit pas
les britanniques sont très pudique donc
on les met à poil devant une femme
l'interrogatoire il est très mal à
l'aise décompose il est atteint dans sa
bataille des musulmans par les
radiographies les autres assurent les
musulmans revenant sur la torture
américaine ouais quand on a frôlé un
contour ou là un musulman qu'on
dissimule on le roule dans une peau de
porc horrible on a appris c avec
l'algérie dans nous les français on
s'amusait à faire ça avec les algériens
dans nos communes soit forcément quand
on a fait ça d'ailleurs
pourquoi c'est fait des erreurs
historiques pour une fois on est devenu
plus buruk les bourgs ou pas c'est ça
quand on est à la guerre cruelle donc en
guerre civile une guerre on se dit que
pour pouvoir la gagner il faut être
encore plus dur que celui d'en face et
donc on s'aligne et on dépasse c'était
une fois que la guerre est terminée on
se regarde ce qu'on est capable de se
regarder dans la glace on y tient c'est
bien ce qu'on a fait c'était utile je ne
pense pas
donc c'était des choses regrettables
j'ai fait une vidéo normalement c'est
sûrement assure mme hachem pour dénoncer
pour dire ça ne sert à rien ça ne sert à
rien torture et c'est contre productif à
terme ça ne donne pas de résultat
pas suffisamment pour excuser la torture
comment vous expliquez que les
américains font des lois pour légaliser
la torture comment vous expliquez que
l'europe tolère des vols secrets de la
cia pour a incarcéré et torturé sur le
sol européen alors c'est pas sur le sol
européen regrets ça les gens qu'on a
torturé ou tué notre espace aérien
l'europe en tant qu'institution n'a
jamais validé sa lancée des pays ayant
voté l'europe l'europe l'europe n'a
jamais validé ce 1 sauf que l'europe
quand l'europe a appris les vols secrets
de la cia en europe
l'europe c'est quoi l'europe l'europe à
bougie l'europe a même pas occulter
la région et droits de l'homme on n'a
pas bougé
en tout cas on regarde dans sa propre
maison et puis nous on essaie de ne pas
faire ce type d ah ils ont fait ça il
n'y à pas de tortue en france et c'est
une bonne chose est une erreur nous à
nos amis américains jeudi à midi
toujours façon ont été traumatisés
évidemment pouvoir par le terrorisme
parle parce qu'ils ont vécu dans le
traumatisme que ça représentait et donc
ils ont surréagi ils ont fait des
erreurs beaucoup d'erreurs et je pense
qu ils se fourvoient et que c'est notre
rôle à leur dire non revenait romain
télé à mettez les pieds sur terre et à
votre stratégie à long terme est
mauvaise et pernicieuse va nous péter au
visage bon revenons à vous un voeu de
petits cours de torture vous a fait quoi
un petit peu d'électricité un petit peu
de substance un petit peu de privation
sommeil un petit peu de blessures sont
posés sur un petit chien un petit peu de
kaboul un petit peu de quoi un petit peu
de tout ça
un petit peu de tout ça non après je
vois pas pas rentrer dans les détails
aussi c'est ce qui est le plus
croustillant ouais mais donc non ce que
c'est vous avez perdu une testicules
comme donc j'ai le monde non non je
crois pas toujours en place quatre
enfants c'est ça ce qui est intéressant
dans cet exercice et qu'on voit pourtant
c'est des gens aguerris à ses forces
spéciales dans la force de l'âge la
trentaine entre 25 et 30 32 ans des gens
physique dur quoi et à chaque fois les
interrogateurs récupère tous les
renseignements il ya toujours un type ou
deux ou trois ans on sait pas trop
d'ailleurs on nous dit pas mais chaque
année les gens craquent après le le but
n'est pas non plus enfin il faut essayer
de résister grâce comme le mute mais on
fait pour résister alors moi je moi je
évidemment dans mon truc non je vous
raconterai pas j'en suis pas mais j'ai
failli craquer un moment parce que il
m'appelait par le nom d'un autre
lieutenant il y alors lieutenant dupont
et alors là moi j'avais pris l'assaut de
la solution n'est plus la solution on
peut essayer de naviguer autour des
questions répondre et c'est moi j'avais
dit je ne dirai rien pas un mot donc
j'étais sur cette posture là je me
disais rien donc torturées et violentées
voix au froide etc et puis
aux glaces et en fait on tremble comme
faire des règlements
et un moment quand il m'appelait et
dimanche entre à réussir l'exercice et
puis ils vont noter tient le lieutenant
du pont il a super bien marché
maintenant je suis pas lieu pour moi
heureusement j'ai résisté je n'ai pas
parlé mais là ils m'ont je sais pas
s'ils l'ont fait exprès j'espère que
c'était c'était intelligent tout cas
j'espère qu'ils ont fait exprès et c'est
là où j'ai failli parler ou alors pour
l'anecdote
détail
votre petite cure thermale ça ressemble
à quoi
non je vous ai dit je vais je veux pas
forcément rentrer dans le détail
l'utilité ce qu'on peut se poser la
question de l'utilité ce truc à quoi ça
sert
parce que si on est vrai véritablement
torture et là on va nous tordre les
doigts nous écraser les mains il ya plus
de limites pourquoi attendre quand on pu
simplement vous laisser sectionné enfin
jouer enfin voilà non il ya plus de
limites c'est affreux quand on sait
qu'on va se faire torturer c'est
l'horreur et donc qui peut résister à ça
je ne sais pas mais disons que le fait
d'être entraînée on voit les techniques
on les comprend les a vécu un peu on
voit le côté le méchant ensuite le
gentil la pause cigarette on se détend
là au moins on va jamais se détend on va
dire attention il va y avait là bas va
arriver donc on donne des petits trucs
faut pouvoir tenir plus longtemps si un
jour on est un groupe d'une opération
n'est dit sur le terrain et nara qui
s'est fait choper faut pas qu'ils
racontent où sont les autres et donc il
faut qu'ils tiennent une heure et pour
que les autres aient le temps de se
cacher de partir de loin marché pendant
toute la nuit ou 10 km ensuite sans
terre voilà donc le but de ces
entraînements ces deux c'est assez
théorique mais c'est de se dire voilà il
faut tenir une heure donc on nous donne
des petits trucs en plus pour tenir plus
longtemps
des petits trucs tout cas non mais c'est
ça de comprendre comment semaine à un
interrogatoire et donc de faire face
toujours le même truc donc si jamais on
est sage irrigue si j'arrive et je vous
mets à genoux sur mes deux carrés de
sucre ouais et que je vous tranche le
nez ouais vous tenez combien de temps
moi j'en serais rien n'est jamais arrivé
si je vous fait manger votre cartilage
de l'oreille est
affreux et d'ailleurs on tient pas et
c'est pour ça qu'ils aient des grands
résistants qui ont en grosses lettres
voilà qui ce qui saute de laitages parce
qu'ils disent qu'ils vont craquer et
donc il se suicider puis il saute un
étage plus bas mans s'il y avait un il y
avait une terrasse et il a il a la force
de ressaut tu es le plus bas pour
pouvoir vraiment s'écraser et arrêté
l'interrogatoire parce qu'il sait qu'il
va craquer c'est magnifique et
m'encourage c'est des gens comme ça qui
nous demande qui manquent oui oui mais
je crois rassurez vous ils sont encore
là et ce que nous agirons je revois
enfin il ya plein de motifs encore de
satisfaction ce que là on est depuis
depuis le début de l'interview on un peu
mirabilis 120 tout va mal tout et
passait pas bien s'est il ya des gens
encore qui croient en ce qu'ils font et
qui vont à fond d'ailleurs je vous en ai
de persuader la population mais est ce
que vous avez fait un stage de chuteurs
opérationnels
non non j'ai fait des sauts en parachute
j'étais page a pas été chuteurs
opérationnels est ce que vous avez fait
le snec vu ça comme tout officier s'est
passé c'est pas troubles de l'insee se
trouve ça c'est à collioure pour et puis
à peu près de là
près des pyrénées où est-ce que c'est
d'ailleurs ces bandes oui on commet
louis collioure et deux sites j'espère
en montagne et
j'accepterai revenons revenu à une
petite torture et
je subis d'autres exercices se dgse sur
des interrogatoires c'était bien c'est
intéressant c'est à dire
s'était fait par un service interne ne
faut pas que je n'ai pas le droit d'en
discuter de services de police ne vais
pas dire lequel
ce qu'ils sont entrain de survie gilet
jaune
[Musique]
et donc qui était chargée donc moi
j'étais sous les jambes j'avais un
exercice je revenais d'un exercice à
l'étranger et je suis attrapé par ces
gens là et ils me font ils m'interrogent
gentiment mais enfin une fouille mes
affaires et ils essaient de voir si
j'arrive à tenir ma légende donc c'est
un très bon exercice qu'on voit un plot
dans le bureau de légende et il y avait
une partie un peu physique d'humiliation
mois après mois avec mon expérience
militaire d'avoir déjà eu des
interrogatoires bon je savais que vous
savez que ça n'irait pas trop grave a
pas filer des baffes qu'on endure de
légende donc du coup bon ça n'a pas
fonctionné mais c'est plus on a des
expériences de ce type la plus on est
finalement armés ça aide si jamais
est-ce que ça arrive quand on est agent
a déjà ce clandestin on peut très bien
se faire attraper par le service local
et se faire interroger et là faut tenir
est ce que vous avez eu le coup des élus
m non cette fois suivant si j'attrape
votre main je vous la tâche un petit peu
et je vous mets des allumettes que je
fais brûler très lentement jusqu'à vos
ongles vous avez eue c'est un an non en
fait vous avez eu un stage de vacances
on reste raisonnable douze des
entraînements vous avez été en guyane ça
sert à rien de s'entraîner à ses
extrémités mais bien compris parce qu'on
peut pas ne pas atteindre ce niveau de
bestialité de réalisme cela là on perd
l'intérêt vous avez été en guyane oui
vous savez comme tous les officiers ça
c'est rien on fait le stage du sceau feu
en guyane vous avez le t-shirt avec
leopard c'est ça non mais donc voilà
c'est un stage qui dure trois semaines
en situation difficile en profonde se
fait par les légionnaires et c'est
passionnant c'est un moment important
dans la vie d'un officier on passe tous
par là et donc on est quand un
légionnaire quand on est jeune et on le
fait pas bouffer pendant une semaine on
est dans une pièce si on pose un gros
oignons crus en plein milieu de la pièce
et ont dit vous avez fait un servez-vous
qui se mettent tous à se battre pour un
vin l'oignon c'est normal c'est pas
normal
est ce que ces entraînements à est vrai
pas pourquoi pas enfin nos leçons de cet
entraînement est vrai regardez moi bien
tant qu il est vrai d'accord bon donc
moi je n'ai pas subi cet entraînement
nous ce qu'on nous faire nous fait
travailler pendant deux jours à
construire une pagode à travailler fort
à couper des arbres et des haies sans
avoir mangé pendant deux jours donc on
est épuisés on n'a plus de force et on
nous donne une dîme pour manger
servez-vous dans la jungle est donc là
on avait un camarade africains mais il
n'était pas dans la section hélas mais
que tout le monde dénigrer un peu noyé
pas très malin et c'est peut-être ce qui
serait bouchon c'est l'affection qu'elle
mieux manger qui trouvait tiens ça tu
peux prendre ça c'est du scoop cet arbre
là tu vas pouvoir manger ça donc ils
auront un an qu'ils ont envoyé du
pouvoir voire donc il y avait trouvé
plein de trucs donc sa section n'a
manqué de rien nous on n'avait pas on
n'avait pas de gens qui connaissaient la
jungle donc du coup on avait plus
d'énergie plus rien on est et on tapait
ont coupé n'attrape très doucement la
plus de plus de moteur puis de plus de
l'essence dans le moteur
revenons à revenons à la torture les
américains iguane d'un amour pourquoi la
france fait pas pression pour que barack
obama ait respecté sa parole montredon
parlons pas
guantanamo ça sert à quelque chose non
pourquoi non on leur fait écouter de la
musique on leur met sur un petit canapé
ils ont petites chaînes aux pieds cette
jolie est ce que ça san radicalise pas
pertinent mais on est complètement
d'accord enfin c'est une erreur les
etats unis se sont trompés et se tire
une balle dans le pied c'est contre
l'histoire et dans n'en reviendra en
arrière et on prouvera que c'était une
erreur fondamentale que vous pensez
qu'on jugera ces gens par exemple le
médecin qui a fait le protocole de
torture de guantanamo l'avocat qui a
permis de faire les lois de guantanamo
le politicien qui a légitimé les vols
jusqu'à guantanamo est ce que est ce que
vous pensez que ces gens là seront
traduits en justice je ne pense pas je
crois qu'ils sentiront pas ce qu'ils
ignorent pardon avec un peu de pognon
pas besoin forcément l'un pognon mais
l'état l'état va se dire c'est une
décision qui a été prise collage etc
collégialement donc qui était assumée
l'état américain assumera et protégera
ceux qui ont choisi de respecter les
ordres donnés par le plus au pouvoir
politique donc je pense que première
puissance mondiale ils vont arriver à
gare à protéger qui vont apprendre
protéger leur leurs officiers leurs
agents d'état quand françois hollande je
pense qu'ils seront pas condamnés quand
françois hollande fait des opérations au
mot en afrique son juge son procès
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut le
traduire en justice est ce que n'a pas
tenu compte en traduire en justice ces
rations homo a l'impression qu'on
flingue des conflits opposant ou des
flingues des terroristes on flingue ce
que vous voulez mettre en branle que ce
soit des terroristes ou quoi que ce soit
on a des lois
est-ce que vous pensez que
ça commence à circuler il faut se
retourner au niveau de la morale il faut
se donner de noms je suis pas au niveau
de la manche je vous somme qu'ils ont
des bras si fort et on peut pas dire oui
là on va tergiverser vous étiez conquis
l'unité 1
oui enfin non montlouis c'est le snack
donc j'étais pas au snack gt gt où je
suis passé au sénat quand j'étais aux
premières pays bas où j'étais à bayonne
et puis quand j'étais aussi ça c'est
rien on fait on va au sneg pour faire le
stage de commandos donc je n'ai pas à
mont louis selon lui c'est le 11e choc
ça s'appelait enfin nom du premier choc
le premier choc
il ya un régiment support qui est le
régiment avec des instructeurs de
commandos dans lequel passent tous les
officiers tous les sous-officiers de
l'armée de terre pour être fort mais
revenons à notre torture et à nos
opérations d'assassinât oui alors quand
vous dites c'est ça c'est il ya eu des
opérations de guerre c'est pas forcément
on a mené la guerre à jaca harraka vous
croyez pas qu'on mène la guerre contre
contre un état contre un état islamique
qui qui a juré notre perte de notre
système de vis d'autres modes de pensée
qui envoie les terroristes dans les
paris qu'ils étaient cinglés joël plus
bourreau clé plus bourg où la question
se pose est-ce que ses bourreaux quand
on fait face à une mitraille imitera et
l'ensemble mais là il imitera et des
gens dans le temps dans les cafés cesser
nos enfances et des femmes et des
enfants
c'est l'horreur absolue ensuite quand on
est dans le canton auront sa réussite
sur un type qui se déplacent en voiture
on sait que c'est cap terroristes ont
fait pas des gages collatéraux parce
qu'on attend très longtemps en face on
passe deux mois avant de décider de
lancer le missile et on se déplace on
tire le missile quand la personne se
déplaçait qu'il n'ya pas de démarche
l'acteur week-end c'est ça mais même les
américains essaient de faire ça et le
fond il essaie de faire c'est à dire
mais c'est à dire qu'il collatérales des
ménages et ce qu'ils essayent de frapper
les gens en déplacement apple comme ils
sont pas le serbe a écrasé cannes le
film ça
non c'est rappeler assange qui a publié
la vidéo de domec était dans un
hélicoptère et qui prenait un malin
plaisir à dézinguer des journalistes
lamentable mais je pense que c'est là la
question se pose moi elle ne choque pas
alors après c'est chaque individu réagit
différemment et mais moralement là on on
peut tuer parce que c'est la guerre
c'est les gens ces gens là sont venus
faire la guerre d' dans notre au coeur
de notre état dans nos rues
dans les théâtres c'est donc c'est moi
je pense que oui c'est de la guerre donc
on draguait on tue et
donc quand on dit en général mais vous
de suivre ça fascine et c'est dans les
cars des lois non c'est une on est en
situation de guerre et on frappe des
combattants et pas de manière des
criminels comme les héros rist nous ont
ciblé combattants
explications accepté merci
bon revenons à quelque chose d'un peu
plus léger vous avez monté une chaîne
youtube
qui ne rentre pas vraiment dans le
détail du renseignement mis à part ce
qu'on peut trouver dans la presse et
dans les bouquins d'espionnage cautionné
par ce qui semblerait être votre
expérience votre expérience de terrain
attendez voilà j'ai pas je me suis
relâché j'ai pas entendu ce que vous
avez dit j'ai 10 ans gagne petit pic non
venons c'était pas une petite pique
c'était en gros votre chaîne youtube
c'est une chaîne très pédagogique sur le
renseignement et madame michu madame
michu ah bon c'est pas gentil me
respecte et magnifie
je pense évidemment c'est pas c'est pas
une chaîne de
je vais révéler des secrets d'état
évidemment c'est pas mon but et puis je
suis tenu toujours je suis retraité je
suis tenu au secret défense donc donc je
vais pas c'est pas mon intérêt de
raconter des secrets donc on va pas y
trouver des secrets fracassant mais je
pense qu'on dit des jeux j'espère des
choses et comme j'ai comme pas mal
d'abonnés dont qu'il trouve des choses
intéressant des jeux de livres souvent
des anecdotes professional véridique
pour appuyer ce que je dis est donc je
pense qu'on peut tout en respectant le
secret défense et dire des choses très
intéressant sur des sujets différents
sur des prises de position et j'espère
être plus intéressant que madame michu
qui n'a pas fait de cette vidéo sur
l'enseignement et qui n'a pas le succès
qu'à ma chaîne vous pensez que vous avez
un succès un petit succès d'estimé
est ce que c'est les services qui vous
en demandez de faire une campagne de com
et ou du moins ils voulaient sert pour
faire une petite campagne de com auprès
de la dgse à votre avis je pense que
c'est une [__] de campagne de classe
alors non ce n'est pas une campagne
d'automne du tout raté
raté ah bah non sinon c'est pas mal a
raté votre donc c'est pas donc j'ai pris
cette décision tout seul quand j'étais
donc j'avais démissionné
donc j'étais au canada et j'ai lancé ma
chaîne et parce que j'avais peur et j'ai
pas demandé j'ai pas voulu demander je
suis un peu rebelle un peu dans l'âme un
petit peu donc j'ai pas voulu demander
l'autorisation de la dgse et donc pour
me faire pardonner ou pour les impôts
pour empêcher qu'ils aient peur quoi
donc j'ai tout de suite créé un site
internet support de ma chaîne youtube il
faut leur dire voilà dont vous ne
trouverez pas je suis tenu par mes
obligations secret défense n'aura pas de
secret faca sang etc c'était à
destination surtout surtout déjà ce pour
lui expliquer donc là des ges au départ
ils ont divulgué est ce qui nous fait
comme vous savez berry 114 parce que
j'ai quand même des camarades encore qui
me parle de temps en temps je veux pas
les mettre en porte à faux donc j'essaie
de ne pas trop leur en parler mais mais
parfois on échange un type e où j'ai
changé maintenant je le fais de moins en
moins souvent donc j'ai des coups à
l'intérieur et donc je sais que ils
m'ont dit mais qu'est ce qui nous fait
le gars béryl et puis ensuite au fur et
à mesure des vidéos dont ils ont vu très
rapidement j'ai sorti une vidéo c'est
elles sont les cinq premiers meilleurs
services de renseignement du monde et je
mettais des 103 peu de lèche c'est ça un
petit peu de lèche maintenant je suis
convaincu qu'on a un très bon rapport
qualité prix qu'on est un très bon
service des renseignements maintenant
c'est tout à fait artificielle de
lemaitre 3e 2e 3e 4e 6e voilà ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens mais pareil voilà donc
j'ai monte je voulais aussi montrer
avance un service que que je pouvais
faire oeuvre utile je voulais pas
cracher dans la soupe c'est pas du tout
monde j'étais ravi passionné par le
travail que j'ai fait et je compte faire
oeuvre utile mais voilà et donc le
navire est ce maintenant qu'ils ont vu
je pense qu'ils ont ils voient bien que
je taquine la frontière et que parfois
je pourrait déraper d'études elle comme
annoncé mais les ouates rsr je me suis
fait chic
bombe a changé composé de se replonger
plus posément dans les clés du métier
c'est ça votre chaîne votre chaîne vous
la décrivez comme ça quand vous attaque
sur le la maison-mère machin vous dites
vous proposer de vous re proue de
replonger plus calmement dont les clefs
du milan je sais pas mais jc vos moore
ces mots ça dans une interview au volant
ce n'est pas dans les vidéos
moi je suis persuadé qu'on peut dire
plein de choses quand je revois
méritez-vous pardon at-il vous frottez
ça fait quoi du bruit c'est pas bien
c'est d'accord puisque micro est loin
mais on l'entend quand même d'accord
donc quand je revois mes vidéos la terre
j'en ai fait 22 quand je les revois une
par une je trouve à chaque fois qu'il ya
des choses intéressantes
il n'y a pas de révélation fracassante
oubli mais quand je raconte une histoire
de renseignement lama dernière vidéo
c'est sur l'agent triple balawi cet
agent jordanien
passionnante on vous l'a vu la vidéo
maintenant vous ai dit que vous êtes en
bété qui provoque la rsa et donc et donc
j'apporte je sais ce qui est intéressant
donc j'ai eu 1 je me suis reposé sur le
travail d'un journaliste américain du
washington post qui a fait un livre de
tripoli jones j'ai oublié le nom je
voudrais m'en vers les noms john warwick
un mec qui disent on citera et déjà ici
dit très mauvais non c'est mon point
faible
vous en avez un deuxième nom bon j'en ai
plein j'en ai quelques-uns c'est quoi
mon deuxième
no comment je sais pas je connais une
fois fait mais j'ai pas forcément envie
d exprimer
j'en parle dans un livre à venir qui
s'appelle profession espion qui va
sortir le mois prochain aux éditions
hoebeke 19 euros 99 un peu - 17 51
semble donc à la portée de toutes les
bourses est-ce que vous avez pas fait
est-ce que vous avez pas fait cette
chaîne youtube en fait pour assurer
votre avenir financier pour pour nourrir
vos quatre gamins et vous de femmes
payer vos deux pensions alimentaires du
mois une pension alimentaire est ce que
vous n'avez pas fait votre chaîne
youtube en fait pour assurer votre
avenir financière alors vous êtes
vous-même youtuber bon après on n'a pas
le même format que vous savez très bien
aussi que youtube
gagnent de l'argent sur notre dos mais
bon nous permet aussi de nous et quelle
est donc la nouvelle
campagne de pub sympa vous avez eu
france inter avec une espèce de
présentatrice qui était totalement en
admiration devant vous qui vous posez
des questions complètement bidon non
c'est pas et c'était bien c'est une
bonne intervenants ces bonnes questions
moi j'aime mm
donc oui alors les jeunes que je ne
gagne rien pardon vous est ce parce que
c'était facile vous avez bien aimé là ce
soir vous aimez un peu moins c'est ça
non non j'ai fait ma muse j'aime bien ça
vous sert de sortir ils étaient
entraînés à rigoler sous la torture
pourquoi pas encore coupe pas une balle
en main parce qu'il ya du ghb dans votre
verre
[Rires]
donc
on dit quoi ouais on va les troubles et
c'est le ghb
votre bouquin
mon bouquin campagne de pub payer sur
youtube alors voilà youtube est ce que
est ce que mon plan
donc oui moi il faut que je retrouve il
faut que je retrouve une activité et
donc donc pour l'instant de youtube ne
me rapporte rien mais effectivement
c'est une plateforme de communication
pour modifier des éditeurs qui sont
revenus sans que j'aie aller démarcher
donc ça c'est agricole donc hoebeke et
puis l'observatoire donc voilà j'ai deux
comptes de geci nier de contrat donc un
livre qui sort le mois prochain puis
l'autre qui sortira l'année suivante
redite - le titre c'est profession
espions et vous pouvez le trouver c'est
un truc c'est une profession c'est un
sacerdoce
on peut utiliser les deux termes et
développer
indifféremment un sacerdoce il faut
c'est un métier difficile avec beaucoup
de contraintes évidemment et c'est un
métier quand on l'exercé longtemps qui
est qui est difficile pour son équipe
personnelle il faut être solide c'est
difficile pour sa vie de famille alors
j'ai une question d'internet que je
prends la voulez là pour un ancien
militaire agent de la dgse il semble
assez déstabilisé face aux questions de
skype pour pour pourquoi reste-t-il
aussi vasif il savait pertinemment à
quoi s'attendre en venant ici alors
qu'il me trouve déstabilisée dont il
vous trouvera certainement un filet
d'eau tiède et quoi il vous trouve aussi
pertinent qu'un filet d'eau tiède à
l'accord bruit et pas très content
d'accord bon bah tant pis pour un tant
pis pour cet auditeur qu'est ce que je
voulais répondre on veut pas tout le
monde on ne peut pas convaincre tout le
monde j'en suis un peu déçu enfin désolé
pour cet éditeur qui ne retrouve pas ce
qu'ils avaient espéré chercher mais
c'est ma démarche depuis le début c'est
à dire je je pense avoir d'être sincère
dans ma démarche
j'espère dire toujours des choses des
choses intéressantes pertinente quand je
fasse l'actualité je réagis avec 15 ans
d'expérience les gse et dont je dis oui
voilà cette opération voilà comment elle
se passe je vois ce que c'est je vois ce
que ça représente donc oui son trou on
peut trouver ça elliptique pas assez
intéressant par on passe vraiment
suffisamment dans les détails des fois
où je botte en touche ne m'exprime pas
suffisamment lourd et tendu tout vous
êtes plutôt sculpteur de fumer ou
brasseurs d'air chaud oignies annie
leroy j'espère j'espère faire une oeuvre
utile et dire des choses intéressantes
je ne vous dis tiens de vous dans les
coins alors je parle de mes premières
années à la dgse et donc c'est un
journal c'est journal d'un espion au
jour le jour donc c'est assez novateur
en ce sens là et deux jours je raconte
la sélection je raconte ma formation
interne les exercices qu'on nous fait
subir les jeux raconte l'entrait la
direction des renseignements sur mes
premiers dossiers puis mes premières
missions à l'extérieur puis je raconte
aussi ma vie sociale ce que je peux dire
mes amis ce que je ne veux pas dire mais
la pauvreté de ma vie sociale
les difficultés de mon couple et c'est
donc c'est cette une c'est une vision
rentrent dans dans la tête d'un espion
ce qui se passe quelle est sa vie au
quotidien peut pas toujours marrante
mais qui est parfois passionnante donc
voilà c'est mes premières années à la
dgse ce que j'ai voulu expliquer à dents
vous regrettez un cerveau brillant saint
cyrien est ce qu'il ya une goutte
d'amertume du tout on se sera à refaire
je ferais le même parcours de az
passionnant c'est un métier passionnant
évidemment une question de race à 5 ans
il vous faut qu'ils tabassent barack
obama prix nobel de la paix ou criminels
de guerre
moi j'ai beaucoup de camps quand on
regarde
un écho quand on regarde et de président
non
américain il y en a quand même un qui
était une classe extraordinaire quand on
le voit un interview au ba ba oui moi je
softpower l'île de smile donc mon
interlocuteur ouvre les grands yeux en
barack obama oui je maintiens moi j'ai
une classe extraordinaire une
intelligence supérieure après
politiquement il a peut-être fait des
erreurs mais bref je trouve que c'est un
président qui avait qui peut tirer les
gens vers le haut qui donne un exemple
remarquable les choses qu'on n'a pas
avec l'actuel c'est évident donc moi
j'ai beaucoup de respect et d'admiration
pour barack obama voilà il ya le chat de
schrödinger qui vous pose c'est pas une
question cc encore quelqu'un qui remet
en doute votre expérience ni franchement
c'est un mythe au total non d'accord
alors on peut être parce que j'avais
beaucoup de commentaires comme ça c'est
mes abonnés au départ en faisant ce type
est un fake c'est un charlot donc là il
découvre il entend là il entend là
l'interview il n'est pas convaincu et
puis dit c'est un charlot bon qu'est-ce
que vous voulez que je réponde à ça je
peux répondre à des choses dire que
depuis le temps que j'existe
depuis le temps que j'existe sur la
scène médiatique ce n'est pas très vieux
c'est depuis un an mais les journalistes
ont fait leur travail et il ya des gens
réalisent qu'ils savent faire leur
travail mais bon quel liquide week-end
pour pas forcément non en face de deux
heures les gens qui les journalistes ils
m'ont interviewé je trouve qu'ils ont
bien fait leur travail et voulons
travailler de merde sauf le papier de
libé qui était pas trop mal car il est
très bien c'est une jeune étudiante qui
a fusé mort dangereuse il a réussi à
faire parler votre femme
un très bon portrait croisé c'est avec
un portrait croisé parallèle avec un
russe la russe donc c'était passionnant
et c'est intéressant de voir qu'on avait
les uns vis mode de pensée conforme et
de la même manière un peu c'était du
très bon train et devrait je l'espère
qui lentement nous et donc donc ses
journalistes ont fait leur vérification
ils ont des sources parfois certains pas
beaucoup d'ailleurs mais ils ont des
sources à l'intérieur du service qui
c'est qui ce type là vous connaissez où
l'on connaît il est de chez nous
il ya des juristes du monde au début que
j'ai eu un premier article qui avait
demandé prouvez moi qu'ils vous êtes bon
j'ai scanné mons passeport diplomatique
par exemple ce qui ne prouve pas grand
chose mais mais malgré tout voilà enfin
bon je pense qu'il ya plus de les gens
qui savent les gens qui connaissent un
peu le milieu ils savent ils savent qui
je suis et qui les gens qui connaissent
un peu le milieu vous les connaissez
vous en avez reçu en partie
les gens qui me connaissent pas mal de
gens qui commencent à me connaître au
sein du service
il ya plus tellement débat maintenant
donc quelqu'un qui qui est sur internet
qui débarque et qui me découvre la
première fois il peut et peut-être
qu'effectivement je suis pas forcément
suffisamment précis parce que je suis
tenu par le secret défense oui c'était
bien fait et donc il peut avoir des
doutes tant mieux c'est bien d'avoir des
doutes il faut et j'encourage ma
communauté votre communauté à toujours
prendre une distance critique pour dire
attention qu'est-ce qui me racontent
c'est faux c'est vraiment un sport où il
était blues noir le
bleu foncé en tous cas presque noir
ouais c'est pas tellement à sa façon je
suis plus normé t il n'était pas comme
ça était bleu bleu marine très foncée
gens plus bleu bleu quoi bleu marine
foncé bleu on est on à une question
sur le pont total en interrogatoire
mythe ou réalité
j'ai je viens de lire le livre
d'un historia
britannique sur oleg donstov non les
gamins sont j'oublie le nom bref le
livre s'appelle
l'espion est le traître ça vient de se
sortir cet été c'est passionnant oleg
cordes genco bourget donc c'est assez
c'est la plus grande source qu'a eue le
mi6 surtaxe était il a été général
colonel du kgb général du kgb même il
était général et c'était une source qui
a travaillé pour les britanniques très
longtemps qu'à donner un renseignement
extraordinaire et ce type là donc c'est
fait il a été trahi ce effet détecté à
cause des baisses le traître de la cia
qui l'a dénoncée aux russes et donc il
s'est fait arrêté interrogé et il est
passé et on l'a droguée donc ils
crachent dans un interrogatoire
et les britanniques elle lui avait filé
une capsule s'il savait qu il
et peut-être comme il rentrait à moscou
il est peut-être se faire prendre non
non je n'ai pas la pression là il a pris
chez lui avant de lancer un booster quoi
qu'il a il était excusée parce qu'il
était voilà et donc ça lui a donné de
l'adrénaline et il se dit donc le poison
enfin ce qui lui en fait boire on n'a
pas marché donc il divaguait mais il
sentait encore la conscience il a pu
résister à son interrogatoire il vous
reste un peu de poudre ouais c'est bon
vraiment ouais effectivement après je
commence à dire n'importe quoi ce qu'a
fait bizarre est un peu fort cc du café
de du guatemala
je vous laisse terminer votre histoire
où je vous pose une question non mais
donc je répondrai à cette question de se
dire c'est à c'est pas un mythe c'est à
dire voilà il ya les russes que l'on
utilisé je passe ça marche très bien je
pense
oui ça peut être utilisé alors j'ai
écouté votre vos vidéos dumont votre
vidéo sur la sphère skripal ils ont
parlé des russes
on avait reçus alain juillet qui quand
même un gros morceau
du coup ce touché le sol et d'une solide
avance expérience patron grosse
expérience expérience de terrain et ses
manies les arbres où il a pris un peu de
bide et imx causera de le dire ah non
c'est plus un opérationnel c'est à
certains c'est un manager c'est un chef
donc on peut on reste toujours comme
quand on est passé par la dgcl on reste
toujours de la dgse on est tous retenus
par par les secrets dont on a eu accès
donc oui mais en ce sens on est toujours
là des gse maintenant je suis plus la
vieillesse retraités sur la sphère
skripal ouais mon pain si vous voulez
alors c'est une vidéo qui m'a valu des
attaques de tous bords avec des pro
russe en partie des guides et peut-être
parler par des groupes de pression
autour des étangs de légende et si des
groupes de pression de checchi non je
pense qu'elle s'y marvel à la sauce en
rien mais en tout cas j'ai eu plein de
gens qui étaient et humour servi la
soupe russe sur cet axe de prusse
c'était que c'était une attaque de l'est
des britanniques qui
il savait plus quoi trouver pour pour
déstabiliser la rue sic et tout est
inventé que qui n'ont rien à voir
là-dedans évidemment que ils l'avaient
ils l'avaient chez eux il a été il a été
puni de prison il avait déjà été
condamnés dont il n'y a pas de raison de
l'assassiner etc enfin ça tient pas la
route et d'ailleurs c'est à la juliette
et reda les positions je trouve un peu
trop pro russe et moi je suis alors je
chute est pas grave j'étais plus aux
affaires dans ces conditions enfin dans
cette affaire dont jeudi pal gpal
l'accès je n'ai pas le détail de ses
opérations mais je suis c'est ma
conviction personnelle qui vaut ce
qu'elle vaut les britanniques les
renseignements britanniques c'est du
solide
d'expérience je les constate essai du bo
l'a vu avec la guerre en irak c'était du
solide ou vrai bon bref c'est
généralement du solide et quand il met
devant leurs hommes politiques en
première ligne des hommes politiques de
suivre la voie ils ont du grain à moudre
et donc il ya c'est facile de dire tiens
mais on sait pas ils n'ont pas dit quand
vous avez une source humaine qui
infiltrent est particulièrement bien
placé et bien vous la grille est pas
vous expliquer pas pourquoi vous savez
ce que vous savez donc vous le dites
peut-être un peu à l'homme politique
voulue êtes un homme politique vous dit
rien faut protéger notre source bah oui
c'est comme ça que ça arrive donc on
peut pas expliquer exactement pour
commencer mais parfois on sait et quand
on regarde les interviews des deux des
deux tueurs enfin bon c'est d'une
crédibilité pitoyable et l'argument qui
dit que les russes n'avaient pas intérêt
à l'assassiner parce qu'il a déjà été
jugé et ensuite il a été changé et c'est
mais ça tient pas la route ont plu parce
qu'évidemment se tient pas il continue à
travailler pour les britanniques parce
que parce qu'il continue à travailler
pour les britanniques et donc ils
donnent continu aux données durance et
pour les russes c'est un traître qui
continuent à être né fasse donc devient
utile de l'assassiner six enfants sont
intéressés si on avait été dans la
position des russes imaginez vous vous
fait tamponner par les iraniens parce
que vous êtes sexuellement attirée par
une iranienne magnifique
et
troisième divorce deuxième oui ça
commence à coûter cher là
le
est-ce qu'on vous dézingue
à bakchich et si je suis traître aol en
jeu franc je prends show heureusement
donc là c'est un traître vous êtes un
élu bien tout de suite
donc là je mange chose donc donc là ces
violations du secret défense est donc
caractérisé le temps et puis donc je
sais plus combien ces deux cent mille
euros 20 ans de prison enfin ça peut
fonder revoir non non non m'exécute pas
non en france quand même est-ce qu'on va
vous chercher pour vous faire payer
mais c'est à dire qu'on va on va essayé
de m'arrêter on va le juger et puis me
mettre en prison me faire payer 220
mille euros c'est une broutille on va
enfin moi ça me ferait mal je sais pas
vous mais peut-être les moyens mais moi
ça c'est elle qui ne sait plus quelles
sont les fait tamponner par les iraniens
vous pensez qu'ils vont mettre 200
millions sur la table ça coûte pas cher
mais là je vais attendre prison voilà je
vais prendre les entreprises auront donc
là c'est dur qu'ils les iraniens vont
aller ils vont pas les médéens ce foutu
quoi
j'ai une question de temps mieux 1 alors
il faut cautionner ça ah bah il faut
être exclue m'a pardonné traître en
excuses est ce que les russes ont bien
fait d'aller chercher leurs traîtres non
chacun et à son le pays dans lequel ils
fonctionnent donc la rue c'est un état
fort ça existe la fameuse communauté du
renseignement oui bien sûr alors allez
les mois tourner vers l'est enfin veille
et le comité des renseignements très
forte dans les pays occidental
occidentaux des files enfin il va être
plus la france souvent et donc là il ya
une véritable
five un
aussi mauvais renseignements sur le
contre-terrorisme les américains de nous
donne énormément de renseignement de
très haute qualité et qui nous est sûre
sur les terroristes français des menaces
qui sur notre territoire et c'est très
utile donc on peut aussi critiquer les
américains c'est bien de le faire il
faut le faire faut pas être aveugle mais
l'histoire veut que face aux américains
la wii enfin il m'a dit on va pas
revenir sur le truc eux et je suis
d'accord avec vous il faut pas il faut
pas être aveugle naïf non
renseignements terreau les américains
nous donne comme ils sont très bons ils
nous donnent des renseignements sur des
menaces réelles et au delà de notre
territoire oui on a on est tellement
mauvais elle a des séries ce grade
tellement les couilles que jesse
maintenant dg ci par là
on est obligé de passer par du n'ya pas
y'a pas de nom on n'est pas obligé mais
parfois il ne peut pas tout voir et
comme sont quand même très bon et qu'ils
ont mis beaucoup d'argent mais les
choses qui n'ont qu'on n'a pas vu et que
l'on veut et nous les communiquent et
donc alors on peut dire tiens ça aurait
été bien pour le voit nous mêmes
évidemment mais en tout cas on prend le
renseignement l'utiliser on arrête les
gens et c'est utile et zahia une
véritable communauté question devant
haas
habilitation sd ou tsd
ouais je sais pas je ne sais même pas
quel est mon d'habilitation et voyez des
sdj pose enfin on est artiste dessaisir
combat très secret défense alors après
je ne connais pas exactement les
classifications les classifications
spécifique à la digestion fait tous deux
on est homme un peu procédure en ce sens
que dans un régiment quand on a du
secret défense non je veux dire on a on
a dit on a on a quelques papiers secret
défense qui sont dans une armoire forte
et puis il faut qu'on tout ils sont tous
marchelli tiens j'ai tel numéro numéro 7
en deux exemplaires le voilà il est là
il est là et sur jean d'êtres humains
donc je fais un pv destruction donc
c'est extrêmement lourd et procédurier
à la dgse à l'intérieur des murs la dgse
tout est secret défense tous nos papiers
on sort un mail il est secret défense
donc on si on avait les mêmes les mêmes
règles on ne pourrait pas travailler
donc
donc on est tous habilité secret défense
tous
j'enquête avant de rentrer donc de la
75e assez pointue
avec des trous dans la raquette sans
doute
question de gilles pense-t-il que le
financement de la campagne de sarkozy de
2007 d'un kadhafi soit une réalité ou
tout du moins crédible alors moi je vais
compléter la question gilles vous avez
parlé d'alain juillet alain juillet a
dit que c'était je me demande je demande
à la communauté un facteur qui
une entreprise de voyous que la dg
souhaitait au courant bien avant le
scandale de médiapart qu'est ce que vous
en pensez kadhafi machin qu'est ce qui
s'passe où
on est frappé par lol l'indignité de
poser ce genre de questions il faut
poser la question parce que parce que
c'est des vrais question est
est ce serait condamnable alors moi dans
quinze ans de carrière j'ai jamais on ne
m'a jamais mis au parfum genre de truc
qu'on m'a jamais demandé il tirait chou
tu prouves pas de questions on
s'échauffe je peux répondre enfin je
répond par une autre question d'accords
qui est qui va arriver après
et donc on m'a jamais j'ai jamais on m'a
jamais donné lors de porter des valises
et puis là on aurait dit tiens tu veux
connaissez des copains qui ont porté des
valises
enfin bref no comments ici session
commune oui ça peut arriver en nous par
hassen qui on revient quatre ont pas là
pas on prend la part de l'autre ou des
choses comme ça non
donc porter des valises ça m'est jamais
arrivé je me connaissez des gens de
l'institution ils ont porté des valises
pas directement des gens qui m'ont dit
attention et des rumeurs on dit ça peut
arriver si ça t'arrive qu'est ce que tu
vas faire mais tout ça c'est un peu
mytho c'est enfin jeu je pense que si ça
se fait et si un homme politique
le fait il va avoir tendance à se
reposer sur les gens qui a entièrement
confiance pour faire des trucs tordus
moi si on demande
amener de l'argent sale pour un homme
politique si je sais ce que ça je vais
pas dire oui je veux pas le faire donc
je pense pas qu'on va s'appuyer sur moi
je pense pas qu'on va s'appuyer sur un
organisme d'état comme la dgse qui va
pas se fourvoyer là dessus ils vont
plutôt faire ils vont plutôt s'appuyer
sur sur des privés ou sur des anciens
agents la retraite
donc donc ça donc c'est extrêmement
grave c'est en dehors des circuits
normaux et si ça se fait ça se fait je
sais pas si ça se fait mais si ça se
fait moi je n'ai pas vu et je pense que
ce genre de chose si ça se fait et j'ai
l'impression que ça c'est fait et donc
ça passe par des circuits occultes or
hors service officielle si je vous dis
hirondelles ça vous fait penser à quoi
ouais bah c'est ce qu'on dit seles et
les femmes on nous envoie des
hirondelles c'est l'expression qu'on
utilise souvent sur pour les services
russes et donc on nous envoie les
chinois et nord-coréen webb a donc c'est
le même principe du coup ces chinois
nord-coréen tous ceux qui utilisent
souvent des femmes pour pour faire
tomber pour faire tomber europe pour
recruter
ga ga iru je tiens à signaler la
communauté que notre invité est un fin
gourmet en gibelin mais ils creusent pas
beaucoup
joué et continuent
donc j'ai fait une vidéo sur le sexe et
espionnage et donc là je parle les
hirondelles donc ça en france on fait
pas on n'aime pas on a peur sont fait
introduire le sexe comme outil comme
levier de recrutement
français ont fait pas ça non on n'a pas
cher je vais un peu musclée la tension
parce qu'ils y aillent à craindre et
c'est à dire une impression de ne rien
apprendre sur la dgse de son
fonctionnement donc ça ça veut dire que
vous êtes aussi pertinent qu'un filet
d'eau tiède donc on va est obligé d'être
pugilat avec vous ouais bah ça marchera
pas
[__] et oued hommage suivi vieux on
n'apprend rien mais peut-être que quand
on fait beaucoup quand on s'intéresse
beaucoup non mais même enfin j'ai des
collègues
je m'insurge et j'ai des collègues du
renseignement de qui connaissent très
bien et qui disent tiens ça c'est
intéressant et enfin on trouve toujours
j'espère toujours des choses
intéressantes et pertinentes à ce que je
dis tant pis encore pour cet autre
auditeur qui n'est pas content mais
ouais bah je vous dis ah tiens il n'est
pas content alors je veux lui dire à
secret voilà alors je vais vous dire ça
alors je ne tomberai pas dans ce piège
là c'est un piège de débutants oui c'est
un peu trop fait
autant dupont dit moi c'est bien vous
n'avez rien de nouveau aux hirondelles
oui sinon je sens la bague et tracy
alors moi je suis déçu ç'a toujours été
je suis frustré d'avoir quitté 15 ans
dgse j'ai jamais été approché par une
hirondelle sauf
lorsque j'étais je quittais mon poste
j'étais avec mon successeur et là on est
tombé sur un peu une hirondelle une
femme député qui s'est présenté députés
en contact avec les services locaux des
gens intéressants plumeau la nationalité
non on a bien votre avis asie centrale
était blonde ou brune
this way bref poêlé ou peu polluants non
non non nickel une femme non bref pas
poli du tout et très voilà c'est une
approche très sexualisée dans un bureau
avec un témoin non ce n'était pas ce que
pas l'horreur mais c'était et j'ai senti
le cul mon succès je suis sorti mon
successeur qui semblait il est
intéressant de cette femme là
j'ai envie de la voir après quoi donc
j'ai fait comme j'étais encore aux
commandes ce que j'étais pas encore
parti donc j'ai vite fait mon rapport en
disant évidemment provocation et
services locaux ne pas rencontrer je
déconseille fortement de continuer à
rencontrer cette femme donc je vais
couper l'herbe sous le pied je sais pas
s'ils l'auraient vu il est une petite
pilule debreu mieux ou pas après
derrière il s'avère un peu engueulé ou
pas du tout je sais pas en tout cas je
ne crois pas il n'a pas continuer à la
voir donc cette c'est ta première fois
où je voyais une approche d'un service
local mais qui étaient destinés à mon
successeur peut-être qu'ils avaient fait
leurs travaux en disant lui attention il
ya une faiblesse sur les femmes
donc moi on m'a jamais attaqué là dessus
j'aurais bien voulu pourquoi pas enfin
j'aurais refusé je serais bref celui-ci
n'est pas trompé
no coment
non
non mais
c'est que review ça reste rare vous avez
eu des
intervenants prestigieux veut pas tomber
dans ceux
des anecdotes qui ne sont pas du bon
niveau d'accord
une question de bob doit-on se méfie de
l'intelligence artificielle
bon sens que la prospective technique
aux jo botte en touche oui peut-être
sans doute alors c'est de la science
fiction va cesser c'est demain mais bon
oui on sait aujourd'hui où vous rendez
pas encore compte un peu comme vos
copins condé monde connecté qui se
battent avec leurs petits footings
sévices est bien cool mais j'ai pays des
taxes pour ces branleurs non mais c'est
des branleurs vous rendez bien compte
le numéro deux de la dgse on a été le
goal et jusqu'à son adresse
je demande à rambo a comme rembourse mes
impôts vous en tant que citoyen c'est
pas vous qui recevait les rapports
secrets mais moi je paye ouais c'est
j'appelle à oui je vois que ils se
grattent les couilles sur les
révolutions arabes ils se grattent les
couilles sur un référendum ils se
grattent les coudes sur technip ça
commence à suffire on peut s'amuser à à
regarder si la france veut dire vous
allez me dire oui mais toutes les bonnes
sections vous savez couvertes par le
secret défense on peut pas vous les dire
mais qu'il travaille ces gens là ils
travaillent moi je vois qu'il ya des
gilet jaune quand même dingue
donc on peut s'amuser c'est chaque
français jr adélie grain a dit gilles
vous en pensez quoi c'est
instrumentalisé par une puissance
étrangère ou c'est je crois que j'avais
déjà posé des questions comme ça
pourrais
je sais pas où je puis aux affaires donc
je serais pas surpris ça pourrait amuser
les russes d'essayer de mettre de
l'huile sur le feu pourquoi pas mais je
ne sais pas où ils avaient un cars
je vous souhaite j'avais lu certaines de
vos vidéos vous disais les américains
nono nous nous ne sommes pas bons moi je
pense que j'avais vu ça sur tf1
fondamentalement fondamentalement c'est
un vrai phénomène de masse moi je suis
dans une région française où j'habite à
la campagne vous aurez pas où mais les
gilets jaunes c'est quelque chose de
très prégnant séverin cdc des retraités
des gens qui ont plus d'argent qu'ils
vivent différents difficilement et c'est
des gens c'est un vrai mouvement de fond
avec une et qui a été en partie entendue
etc il ya une vraie détresse de ces gens
là qui ont comparé ces difficiles des
gens qui bossent beaucoup et qui qui
gagne très difficilement leur vie et ses
cd pénibilité il ya il ya trente ans un
pauvre quelqu'un enfin qui gagnait le
smig il arrivait à vivre correctement
être heureux maintenant dans notre monde
moderne vous n'avez pas une connexion
internet vous êtes des classes et si
vous n'avez pas électricité tout le
temps enfin bref vous avez il faut voir
de voiture vous pouvez pas vous chauffez
où vivait dans un clapier kimi de la f1
avec avec miller avec le smic
aujourd'hui vous êtes et vous avez des
enfants vous êtes un miséreux et c'est
c'est triste d'en arriver là et donc je
comprends la détresse des gilets jaunes
donc à une vraie détresse qu'est ce que
ça peut être manipulé ensuite pourquoi
pas mais je pense qu'il ya un mouvement
des conti et l'usap non imposables les
révolutions non après ça peut être un
compact ça fait ça peut être accompagné
je crois vraiment on peut y lire un
conte et fenêtres utilisés après on s'en
tient là il se passait quelque chose d
intéressant mais je crois je crois en un
véritable phénomène de masse non
prévisibles au départ ça monte là parce
que les gens
genre on en marre et ça monte mais
ensuite ça très vite récupéré pas quoi
mais attendez on va s'arrêter deux
secondes non prévisibles les révolutions
arabes c'est une blague ou quoi
c'était sans doute prévisible on a passé
la cible
c'est-à-dire un service mais henri
guaino c'est là déjà bien dit là-dessus
ce n'était pas mal donc je vous dis à
dérider disent ils ouais mais c'était
s'était il l'a très bien dit non c'est
pas la peine de revenir sur ce que le
services de renseignement il fait pas de
prospecter ou parfois il a une femme de
ménage non bien sûr que non non je pense
qu'il faut poser aussi la question à
ceux qui sont destinataires de nos
renseignements de notes secrètes des
fossiles non c'est à dire c'est eux qui
ont le renseignement secret assez il est
pas destination du grand public alors ce
qui arrive ce qui ressort le douanier
n'oublie claude guillon clodion
sélection qu'on apporte aux français en
limitant des actions terroristes sur le
sol en protégeant peut-être mal
insuffisamment des entreprises
françaises etc ça vous fait du
renseignement et hénault président ils
ont la pression de vie retire à la dgse
depuis 10 ans 20 ans a fait des progrès
on se sent bien renseigné il ya des fois
sur des dossiers difficiles par rapport
à l'ailier américain on sent qu'on a des
billes et qu'on est soutenu et qu'on
sait les choses et ça nous aide donc
abandonné quand vous donnez une note à
manuel valls ou quand vous vous apprenez
que l'autre guillon lit vous vos notes
ça vous arrange bien parce que là ça on
provoque on provoque et puis là de
gentiment gentiment gentiment mais mais
quoi donc moi ça ne me dérange pas il ya
un côté il ya un côté jeu balle de ping
pong etc mais au bout d'un moment tout
quand on écoute les gens vous
connaissent donc savent que vous avez le
côté que
provocateur pour justement
créer une réaction etc mais c'est le
seul est ce que vous pensez pas
forcément ce que vous dites on a dit on
et demi qui aime bien châtie bien voilà
c'est ça voilà on est là pour nous en
sortir les doigts du cul et c'est à dire
en restant d'étendre la force vous avez
tout à vous vos interventions
intempestives au boss regardez cette
vidéo on s'amusait mais l'ancien boss
ouais on a rien à [__] la paix de
bosses ont fait on fait passer le
message
une autre passage c'est sortez vous les
doigts du cul mais se sortent les doigts
du cul donc voilà à force de faire des
questions provocative tout le temps en
fait en au bout d'un moment on se dit
les gens qui écoutent quoi constructive
oui bah oui sur des vrais sujets sur des
vraies questions c'est vrai c'est bien
mais au bout d'un moment c'est on va
regarder ça pendant deux heures on va se
dire mais qu'est ce que c'est que ces
branquignols ayez à l'idée bourg ouais
donc si c'est moi ça va c'est pas grave
mais mais c'est ça on peut pas c'est un
service qui travaille bien c'est des
gens à sortir du cul oui il ya peut-être
des gens qui ont fait des footings
mauvais endroit que c'est qu'on fait des
erreurs mais on peut pas être un sais
pas peut-être hills et ils se sont fait
gauler certains journalistes voici un
journaliste est capable au pied des mecs
qui font des footings en théâtre
d'opération c'est des [__] de crétins
c'est juste des [__] de crétins pays
avec mes impôts mais on en parle on va
reparler dix fois dans ce footing là est
donc là on néglige le travail de gens
qui travaillent h 24 le week-end qui
reviennent et qui font un travail
remarquable c'est pas mon problème
bah oui mais moi c'est aussi sont ils
sont lentes et ils ont mis dedans j
ressort d'un service ils ont mis en
danger encore et encore ça fait rigoler
mais quel est le risque
qui fait 90 une opération à partir de
renseignement etc à la base elle est
protégée elle à son système de sécurité
on n'a pas et quand on pense à rien je
vois quand on voit al quaida faire des
opérations de rang sur notre propre
territoire par exemple il s'avère qu'ils
avaient gaulle il un mec était d'une
centrale nucléaire il allait poser une
caméra devant chez lui
pépère
pépère nous on a des gars qui font des
petits footings avec des mondes
connectés de temps en temps il faut
peut-être que la société vienne leur
rappelle qu'ils aient ce qui les payent
12e mention de la mode connecté
et qu'est-ce qui les paye moi je la
grande majeure la très grande majorité
des officiers traitants et des des
agents de la dgse travail
avec énormément de conviction et travail
qu'ils font du bon boulot et ça bosse
bien et donc on peut pas c'est agaçant à
force de ramener toujours en disant
voilà ces [__] nous impôts passe dans
ces erreurs de deux mondes connectés on
va on va regarder que ça alors que le
travail de la legacy est assez de classe
et j'avais de la chance que je sois pas
théoriquement si j'ai ce type
d'information avant que je travaille
pour une puissance étrangère je peux
vous dire que je peux faire des
étincelles
shi des feux d'artifice avec passion
c'est un détail alors moi aussi avec ma
formation d'espions si j'étais
terroriste je sais comment contourner
les choses c'est faire mal oui ça c'est
possible d'accord ou si vous inquiétez
pas on est défaillant nar mavericks nous
pose une question l'otan denis jour est
elle une vitrine pour couvrir les
bavures des pays membres
peut-être été cas sur certains points
nous faut bref évidemment c'est un peu
réducteur de
deux
de rabat s'est rabaissé l'otan à 7 cette
formule on s'est un peu d'accord une
question de louis intelligence
artificielle puisse pas les tirs - il
sait pas ce que c'est peu dire
intelligence intelligence artificielle
puisse pas l'anti requis et les risques
des logiciels us dans l'univers du
renseignement encore ralentir c'est quoi
dans l'agrégat jaffray quoi un
agrégateur d'accord
et donc la question j'avais
alors l'ia c'est de la science fiction
l'autre il simule
[Musique]
alors une question un peu un peu pataud
c'est un peu sociale un peu à quel point
sa carrière à la dgse a impacté sa vie
sociale
et bal à affecter lourdement fond c'est
à dire des menaces en effet le premier
divorce
en partie peut-être il ya plein
d'explications différentes intime des
erreurs et c'est donc non mais quand
j'ai changé
je suis
devenu retraités c'est là que je me suis
apprécié une fois à partir du moment où
on débranche un petit peu le le câble
c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit que on a
manqué beaucoup de choses c'est vrai
qu'on a mais année dgse je n'avais pas
de l'église social j'avais une vie
sociale très pauvres parce qu'on peut
pas avoir d'amis à partir du moment où
se faire de nouveaux amis à partir du
moment où quand on discute eh bien on
elliptique sur son propre métier qui
nous occupe la grande majorité de notre
temps et donc on peut pas raconter ce
qu'on fait et donc on a fait pas d'amis
ou peu ou ses amis intéressés ses amis
en mission et donc c'est des gens qui
savent qui on est et donc
à travers nous ils savent qu'ils parlent
représentant la dgse locale donc on a
pas une vraie vie sociale on n'a pas
d'amis et ça c'est un c si les gens ont
envie de rejoindre la dgse c'est quelque
chose dont on a plein de satisfactions
par ailleurs c'est un métier passionnant
on prend des risques c'est de
l'adrénaline c'est du plaisir c'est du
jeu c'est du cdh on sent utile mais en
contrepartie on a une vie sociale
difficile
une dernière question et puis après on
posera une question d'un
habituel qu'est ce que vous pensez des
black blocs une question de temps tel si
les black blocks bon je pense que ça
mais les mecs avec des cagoules qui
casse tout et qui marque sur des murs a
qu'un ou le cops are bastards
moi je me prends mon accent ouais
on a compris
bon ça me paraît un peu déplorable je ne
cautionne pas évidemment donc qu'est-ce
que je devrais penser on peut détruire
une société fala cdc des forces occultes
ou cd c'est
des choses qui dès ce qui casse tout un
projet de vie sociale une organisation
ses dangereuses et il faut combattre ce
genre de dérives voilà une vraiment
derrière question parce que c'est est
revenu sur certains et qu'il faut la
plus la poser pour crever l'abcès
question bob les hauts placés de la dg
se sont ils tous francs-maçons alors
bien quelqu'un qui dit
je sais sa réponse j'en sais rien c'est
pas mon domaine eh ben je vais les
décevoir
sk une enquête du fait par les services
internes du fait qu'il ya une
appartenance à une certaine loge une
certaine obédience est ce que ça sera
interdite est ce que ça serait une gui
tiens vous est franc-maçon dont vous
serez pas la dgse je ne pense pas
ensuite
moi une des déceptions
une déception au service en 15 ans et
pourtant j'ai gravi les échelons je suis
arrivé j'ai une bonne situation j'étais
un officier qui comptait qui est bien
marché j'ai pas été contacté par la
franc maçonnerie pour dire voulez-vous
être des nôtres un peu vexé j'aurais dit
non mais donc ça n'est pas arrivé donc
premier point de réponse ensuite les
gens disent qu'il ne faut pas non pas
crier sous les toits qu'ils sont
francs-maçons mais la rumeur interne il
ya un tel est franc-maçon tel loges il
son humeur interne vous bossez dans les
services de renseignements vous n'êtes
pas capable de savoir quelle obédience
et qui ne m'intéresse pas je ne fais pas
de renseignements sur mes collègues et
son cadre en interne parce qu'on secoue
l'intéressement pourquoi parce que ça ne
m'intéresse pas mon renseignements cette
femme n'est pas savoir qui vous bossez
que c'est dû me renseigne non en partie
moi c'est de nos renseignements il faut
pas se tromper d'ennemi l'ennemi et
extérieur c'est mon dossier on les livre
intérieur est ce que est ce que nous
notre service à la dgse ces faits poutre
est infiltré vers l'est par des
puissances étrangères
j'espère que non je ne pense pas non
donc après chaque service de
renseignement
j'attendais une réponse en telle année
j'ai lancé une enquête sur tout mon
service avec des chiens de guerre des
moines bénédictins qui ont épluché le
passé jusqu'au nom du du du mari de mes
beaux parents divorcés mais là il
fallait interroger quelqu'un d'une autre
ancien de près de proximité où vous a
demandé de retrouver les prénoms en
d'edu du les grands-parents dont frais
et qu'ils étaient mariés machin chose il
ya huit ans divorcée si vous voulez des
questions de salaires ce type de réponse
il faut deux interrogés qu'un officier
de la dgse du service de sécurité par
exemple y rentrer et on rentrera pas
dans les détails il vous dira pas
évidemment mais moi moi je vous raconte
ce que j'ai vu ce que j'ai fait moi on
m'a pas demandé de faire des mener des
enquêtes internes à l'intérieur sur mes
collègues vous rendez compte déjà on est
un peu parano ya un petit peu on peut
être si on commence à travailler sur ses
collègues pour savoir ce qui se passe
vous avez un service de renseignement
les fesses b ça lui arrivait du kgb dans
la main bonne époque c'est tout le monde
se voit on se regarde en chiens de
faïence en n'ayant pas confiance ensuite
la côte est et donc vous créer un
service complètement inopérationnel et
inefficace quand vous travaillez de
cette manière là donc moi je vous dis ce
que j'ai vu ce que j'ai fait j'ai ça
m'intéressait pas devoir bien été grand
pardon regardez-moi avait
donc dans voilà moi je sais qu il se
disait à l'intérieur et ça ne venait pas
eu envie de pousser qui quoi comment qui
est la preuve de prendre en photo dans
une réunion qui tiens voilà c'est tous
des francs maçons je ne sais pas qui
faisait quoi moi on m'a pas proposé
j'aurais été un peu vexé mais j'aurais
dit non et est ensuite volant et oui il
se dit à l'intérieur que lui un tel est
franc-maçon j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
pas mal de formations et des gse c'est
mon impression personnelle et je n'ai
aucune preuve là dessus et ça on arrive
à la fin notre interview ça fait combien
de temps ça ça fait
deux heures et 25 minutes avec alain
rollat ça va vite et on n'a pas vu le
temps passer
comme on vous a trouvé relativement
sympa bon nom lors lors des déçus
commune qui décime pourquoi l'ordre
alsacienne des ce qu'ils disent
donc on s'est peut-être votre rôle qui
vous suivent jusque chez nous
on arrive à la fin de notre interview
comme vous a trouvé sympa on va vous
proposer nous proposer trois livres à
lire et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
alors donc le dernier livre que j'ai lu
je les cite est un peu grillé je le
trouve passionnant donc c'est vraiment
une histoire d'espionnage d'agents
doubles le très haut niveau on a
rarement eu un agent de 2,2 ce niveau là
donc c'est le traître est l'espion
de ben j'oubliais encore le nom de
l'auteur mais bref si si on tape sur
internet on trouvera le traître l'espion
c'est un historien britannique ce qui
est très intéressant avec ce livre c'est
qu'il a interrogées l'espion lui-même
russe pendant des dizaines d'heures
d'interviewer puis l'a interrogé les
officiers traitants britannique il a
interrogé des russes il interrogeait la
femme du type est donc donc c'est un
document complètement véridique et on a
vraiment c'est donner la parole à
l'espion lui-même donc c'est moi c'est
des reflex professionnel que je
comprends que j'ai vu donc je sais que
tout est vrai et en tout cas c'est très
véridique c'est passionnant donc ça
c'est un livre à lire quand on aime
l'espionnage au pub où le nom de votre
bouquin or le maire ces professions
espion je vais pas le mettre dans les
trois mais évidemment si vous m'en
donnez 4 je veux dire le mien je vous le
conseille
je pense que cet orgue et travaux disco
17 euros 50 je crois je pense que ça n'a
pas été écrit comme ça c'est nouveau
c'est novateur et c'est pour qui veut
comprendre comment ça se passe la vie
d'un aussi traitant la dgse c'est très
intéressant très informatif malgré tout
ensuite
bon évidemment mon livre de chevet celui
qui m'a fait rentrer la dgse c'est c'est
john le carré la trilogie ce replay mme
c je trouve ça évidemment
merveilleusement écrit c'est passionnant
parce que c'est le smiley le type
bedonnant le great man par excellence
est pas james bond mais il domine son
sujet parce qu'il est intelligent parce
qu'il fait d'analysé parce que ils
recrutent il concédé ouvre
alors mon troisième livre hoover
quand le président américain
qui ouvre le coin
hoover
un directeur de renseignement américains
il était gay ou n'était pas gay j'en
sais rien je m'en fous donc ils mentent
mois dernier un livre donc je vais pas
faire de renseignement je vais un peu
mais lever un petit peu pour faire un
peu de littérature un peut-être mon
livre préféré
c'est la puissance et la voir de guan
green ce que j'aime dans cette histoire
là c'est que c'est c'est l'histoire
d'une rédemption c'est un homme qui est
mauvais qui est qu'il ya des défauts
terrible et qui va se révéler et qui va
faire des actions mère merveilleuse je
crois beaucoup à cette capacité de
l'homme à s'améliorer on fait des
erreurs le renseignement pareil c'est un
métier difficile on peut faire des
erreurs d'analysé je crois qu'on peut
toujours progresser et devenir meilleur
et voilà ce type de romance salle élève
l'esprit c'est pour ça que vous avez
fait une chaîne youtube non mais est ce
que vous avez fait votre chaîne youtube
pour absoudre non plus non plus ce qui
m'énervait peut-être c'était de voir que
la parole elle est confisqué par des
gens qui ne savent pas trop et qui vont
par les renseignements qui sont les gens
qui bossent 1 qui travaillent qui sont
des universitaires c'est très bien il y
en a qui font du très bon travail mais
parfois je retrouvais pas ce que j'avais
envie d'entendre et je me dis non c'est
pas ça alors c'est pas ça le travail de
la jso sait pas donc je pense que c'est
pas mal qui est un ancien espion chi
chi puis qui peut s'exprimer lui-même et
dire ce qu'ils pensent tout en restant
dans des limites acceptables du point de
vue du secret défense je pense qu'en
restant à ses limites on peut dire des
choses intéressantes donc si vous le
faites très bien c'était ça ma démarche
oui et puis il ya le ballon a juste eu
un vrai on veut les supplications entre
les deux affaires karachi
alors à quoi elle ressort la marne
raconte un peu papa parce que maintenant
vous êtes suffisamment attendri pour
vous pouvez en parler
ouais là j'ai j'ai eu des éléments
que je ne peux pas révéler parce que je
les ai appris en fonction donc c'est du
secret défense
bref
et puis en plus a jugé encore donc je ne
peux pas me permettre de dire quoi que
ce soit j'ai l'impression que des trucs
un peu bizarres dans le fait qu elle est
dure et les hautains et le parquet qui
demandent un procès non voilà je rentre
à beaujeu
question de gens de la france en tout
cas l affaire karachi voilà je n'en
dirai pas plus je vais devenir peut-être
encore des gens déçus de façon j'ai pas
besoin de
nous plaire à tout le monde c'est je ne
pourrais pas dire en dire plus
on arrive à la fin hélas un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
quelque chose d'un père issad qui va
rester sur le bisou
mois il faut essayer d'être il faut
essayer d'être un peu optimiste parce
qu'on en a une on vit une période
difficile alors la jeunesse sait c'est
une capacité d'émerveillement de
capacité une force d'imagination une
énergie tout ça c'est des qualités dont
on a besoin pour essayer de faire
quelque chose rendre notre monde
meilleur il faut se révolter un petit
peu pour des vraies causes et causes qui
en veut aux lacs en valent la peine et
bon c'était tu peux pas tous maintenant
de dire ça mais je pense que les
questions environnementales voilà notre
planète fout le camp et je vis à la
campagne c'est des valeurs auxquelles je
crois je pense que quand on voit le
réchauffement climatique les gens des
millions de personnes vont vite dans les
endroits qu'ils vont devenir invivable à
courte échéance c'est des vrais
problèmes de fond est bon si la jeunesse
peut se mobiliser et faire pression sur
nos hommes politiques pour dire
attention ça nous apporte on va on est
tous sur la même planète on va tous
crever à petit feu il est temps de faire
quelque chose donc si la jeunesse peu
ne pas suivre l'exemple d'une mauvaise
génération qui n'a rien fait et qu'il
a eu de relever le flambeau et d'essayer
de traiter les choses tant qu'il est
temps
de juste une dernière question d'un
internaute
d'expresso il est meilleur chez vous
chez cimb ue
bah alors s'il est un peu particulier
ici
il ya un peu renseignement russes pour
les interrogatoires l'ont bien le russe
thérapeutique de mer noire mais chez moi
locale
j'aime bien j'aime bien celui là oui il
est pas mal il est bien c'était de
c'était du guatemala et du bélize on
remercie notre internaute béryl 614
merci de vous être prêté au jeu et à
bientôt à bientôt merci coupé
[Musique]
e